on salue vlad c'est le kef salut tout le
monde
bon finalement je joue au yoyo fameux
studio de québec elle femmes aux studios
et alors qu'est ce qu'on pense
aujourd'hui j'adore
il faut chaud à calais où il faut chaud
à marseille mais c'est ce à quoi
s'attendre lorsqu'on est à cannes pour
moi de jouer à la chaleur chaque mois
justement après moscou il faisait tous
les jours au quai au plus 17
ça fait un bon changement non ici fait
mais il sait pas trop chaude encore tu
arrivé au mans il fait oui fait meilleur
attendu là il faut juste qu'on soit en
ligne vlad ouais ça y'en en ligne c'est
sûr il ya notre chaise qui quittent
écrit éclata le chat
oui ça lui le mec tu vas voir il ya des
nouvelles têtes
il ya des fans notamment lieu de vie qui
tu as écris plusieurs mails à saluer le
génie de dôme en tête du montage à et
l'effort il est très fort franchement je
sais pas s'il est déjà arrivé mais il va
il va arriver dans tous les cas et donc
en fait c'est pas nous qui sommes en
retard c'est juste qu'on ait une
information que ça colle match
commençait à 18h vis avec un retard donc
on a commencé à 18h10 mais je vois
toujours pas de match donc qu'est ce que
tu penses de ces deux joueurs
sarah naeem parce que moi j'ai mon poil
de view c'est pas que je les connais
très très bien mais j'ai vu ou plusieurs
parties de la part de chacun qu est ce
que toi tu empruntes paraît que tu peux
te dire qu'il ya un troll tu sais ce que
c'est un troll mais cela en fait il ya
un truc marrant c'est que dans le staff
de chasse comme il ya une fille russe
que tu connais
equipe-type choses comme je paillard son
nom de se remettre tout le monde sort
qui sait après il ya deux voies j'allais
pas dire son nom pour pas là cités qui a
écrit un truc très marrant comme la
sélection des joueurs
elle a dit c'est même pas la peine de
sélectionner sahara n'a c'est sûr qu'il
va gagner il est beaucoup trop fort
pourquoi et donc avec elle vient de
gagner un seul tour mois en fourguant sa
vie où est donc avec fable comme on est
mort de rire avec après ça on a rigolé
on a décidé de dire que tous les matches
avec sarah ne servent à rien et on est
d'ailleurs très heureux qu'ils jouent
pas le grand prix fit qu'on commencera
dès demain pour pas tuer l'intérêt de la
compétition
pascal est non mais ajuste allah dit
qu'il fallait prendre au speech est
championship adultes parce que bon s'ils
l'emportent qu'ils peuvent en prendre
les compétitions adultes excusez moi
mais moi j'ai 45 ans des gens parlant d'
aujourd'hui je n'ai vu autant que en
fait ça veut rien dire juste celui rien
dire du tout encore et ça n'a aucun lien
de jeu après forêt vient de gagner à
très fort tournon en russie mais par
contre à ma connaissance il n'a jamais
était encore considérée en tant que
phénomène rue tandis que leo mais
craignent un mac sous loue une fois elle
a gagné le championnat junior avec le
risque d'afficher risques et surtout
view les qualités de ce parti un moment
donné tout le monde a pensé que
peut-être à ce nouveau phénomène
depuis personne ne parle tout le monde
pense à surfer rosa mais personne ne
pense plus au max de moxico
mais vous savez avec les jonas jamais
rien fait parce que parfois tu vois en
jaune je pas de 17 ans 18 ans il joue
2006 pas plus tu leur voix d'hommes
quatre mois ça y est tu vois déjà à
melbourne dès 2006 66 oui ça m'arrive
est pas mal de fois et par contre
souvent après il retombe juste que je
pars 2006-10 2006 van et progresse plus
oui donc avec les jaunes tant que ce
n'est pas justifié
comment dire ce n'est pas à la sphère
ajusté encore donc ans et j'aimerais
donc c'est double intrigue doullens
trick de ce match par contre je dois
dire à mon truc view les parties que je
viens il est tout à fait clair pour moi
que mocsai océane faux faux savants gens
qui jouent chaque partie jusqu'au bout
et qui essaie de prouver qu'il est
nouveau c'est cher quoi il s'est ramassé
un représentant de cette génération
jeunes cygnes il prédit que joe
quelqu'un fort avec les boires et le tir
ce petit news dès le premier coup je
veux dire que quelque part c'est la
seule page des styles de ces le crash
des approches à lévis en général d'où
l'intérêt avant mon intérêt pour ce
marché
mais du coup pour avoir vu les deux
joueurs jouent et moi je mettrais quand
même mag fin par am
en fait on aura la paix comme ça favori
du match parce que sarah n'a il a déjà
galéré contre issy kengo et il me semble
qu'il n'est pas si fort que ça en fait
mais le problème c'est curieux selon les
partis en cadence rapide surtout en
please do max brooks chez eux
à vrai dire il m'a pas beaucoup
impressionné quand même je veux dire que
le jeune j'ai l'impression que quand
même et oui marques du temps pour faire
les calculs et les calculs dans son
style représente quand même
grande partie donc pour moi je batte
favori jusqu'à présent il est clair que
moi je joue c'est pour parents tout à
fait parce que son approche à lévis ne
pourrait plus mais l'issue du match
n'est pas clair du tout pour moi je
retourne et équipe le faux en cadence
ralentie dans split en cadence boulettes
et où quelque 1 200 points de plus que
moi pas
en bis quand même ça veut dire beaucoup
ça c'est alors que sarah n'a peut-être
moins creux quand je sais pas je sais
pas je n'ai pas le pseudo de sarah n'a
en fait je sais pas si c'est
politiquement incorrect à dire mais
[Musique]
parmi mes collègues j'ai entendu quand
même les rumeurs sur les résultats de
jaune dernière en blitz
ok c'est que des rumeurs et moi je les
partage pas parce que moi je viens d'où
non je veux juste leur partage ce qui au
géant tandis que les braves
non parce que si c'était d'europe ça n'a
juste pas sûr pour qui n'importe qui ce
tricheur mais je les partage pas juste
partage des coûts ce qui est des rumeurs
que tu entendu où est justement rien de
plus c'est même pas mon avis en tout cas
ischios sa cause et quels lots au
classement à dos ses ravages sont en
fait je ne reconnais pas son pseudo et
je pense qu'il n'est pas connectée parce
que je pense pas qu'ils aient moins que
moi en fait donc je pense pas que ça
puisse être lui topo tune
non et vous les gars qu'est ce que vous
pensez pour vous et il faut voir il peut
être vous connaissez plus que moi déjà
sur les deux contestant aujourd'hui
c'est sarah naquit en retard très
clairement parce que le match a été
retardé et donc si le match était
retardé c'est qu'il ya un problème pour
un joueur et paramé connecter à et les
miss miss annick sur chase co ok c'est
le vrai voit tout ce temps dans le g
écoutez moi je prévois mélenchon donc
malheureusement je n'ai pas appris
encore cette technologie de d'être un
peu partout tu sais d'ailleurs que je
suis pas moi populaire que mélenchon je
sais mais beaucoup moins fois au niveau
technique
tu sais qu'on est toujours cette phrase
maintenant sur les sur les montages ta
fameuse citation de toi t'es nul moi je
m'appelle paul morphine sarama fauverie
je devrais jouer avec les adieux les
yeux bandés le culot de la fois dieu
pour que ce soit écrit c'est ce que je
dis
avec sarah n'at on a inventé tout un
nouveau monde qui est beaucoup trop
faible sont nombreux les formes de vie
c'est qu'hier on a même trop laid tu
connais un journaliste norvégien tarjei
boe rejet tu sais qu'on a trop les hier
sur twitter oh tu sais que je excuse moi
pour 1,30 euro pour une petite seconde
je suis en forme des séries est utilisé
surtout des séries toulousain historique
et lorsque l'on parle par exemple des
rois espagnols du 16e siècle chez chaque
celle au cours de chaque mois y avoir
une chronique et les han han guan est
clair sauver qui décrivait la vie
quotidienne du roi pour génération
oui mais ça existait sur shenhua oui
donc tandis que des rejets comment
s'appelait le berger à la bergère
chanteur il à revendre ce pauvre 22
premières circulent les chroniques les
officiels du haut du roi magnus le
premier
quoi qu'est ce que c'est que ça à chaque
fois écrire qu est sûrement news à quel
point mais les g quel point les mots
cnjs inimitable je sais pas me legros
n'existe plus haut débit la grande
révolution française n'est ce pas mais
du coup qu'est ce qu'on a fait hier et
il dit que magnus a gagné huit tournois
d'affilée et on a découvert avec fabien
en commentant on discute on discute on
discute et tout d'un coup on se rappelle
que maxime a gagné le dernier 3 bis en
norvège quand même et on a fait un tweet
avec magnus je viens juste de gagner
deux trois d'affilée hashtag fake news
hashtag tchèque par les critiques et du
coup il a répondu en disant que non que
c'est un tournoi qui comptait pas mais
en fait ils décident quels tournois
compter qu'elle te raconte pas qu'on va
ça comptait pour le classement place
oui mais qu'est ce qu'il raconte à l'eau
banon il dit donc la crainte qui rouille
ou faux ça compte comme oprah combat mot
l'iof new skies et par jeu ce faire il
faudrait lui mettre le même de trucks en
dessous le gif quoi y refaire contre je
dois dire que je suis très impressionné
par les photos de sa femme je pense
qu'il ya une très grosse compétition
entre les formes de jeu n'offre
éléphants de svendsen
au niveau de la des photos intimité de
la proche d'ailleurs tu sais que lorsque
en 2004 ou 2007 je me rappelais plus ou
moins mon frère est organisé le concours
de beauté jésuitique mentale plusieurs
mois sa femme a été en tête parce que il
est en game une langage et une armée de
trolls qui ont voté pour elle c'est pas
mal ça ouais donc ici à part deux fois
et ku ça me parle de fabrique de troller
tout en quelques sortes et là l estp
mère de détroit des achats de votes
oui de ça deux achats nouveautés j'adore
tellement ce hashtag fait que news gelé
alors attends ça va démarrer on voit les
commentateurs américains qui ont l'air
très heureux nous je te dis tout de
suite hier on s'est fait chier
eux ils sont très heureux nous on s'est
fait chier clairement hier pourquoi
après 1h15 de jeu il y avait déjà plus 6
[Musique]
et le problème c'est que van de forest
est retourné dans les bois dis moi
honnêtement s'il te plaît dis moi
honnêtement qu'est ce que tu penses qu
est-ce que plus intéressant à suivre les
compétitions sur piste comme des femmes
ou les compétitions de juniors les
femmes les femmes sont beaucoup plus il
ya plus de rebondissements ou non mais
déjà il ya un truc je viens deux je
viens de revenir de dieu du tournoi du
candidat karzaï et je sais à quel point
c'est moins sûr et le tournoi le tournoi
final mais il ya un autre truc c'est
qu'en fait ça à joues pour un genre de
titre comment te dire là les juniors pas
quand même l'impression de regarder mais
qui sont pas au top
ah d'accord les phares et que ce qu'un
disque à se dire pas compter le même nom
mais regarde c'est comme ok tu regardes
federer nadal tu regardes serena
williams qui va jouer en finale contre
simona halep
mais wimbledon juniors en fait
qui on a quelque chose à faire j'ai même
jamais regarder un match de manif en
faites ce que vous voulez je vous entre
vous quoi vous savoie c'est bizarre en
fait qu un moment donné je pensais
qu'ils ont en fait parmi les champions
du monde juniors je pense qu'il ya assez
bio du monde qui a réussi une grosse
carrière après en fait je peux citer
point de nombre de ceux qui ont des
visées sont devenus les champions du
monde juniors et après rien de spécial
ok bahreïn joue avec les bois jo
s'opposent regarde comment y compris
viau il y aura beaucoup de cavaliers toi
je crois au premier coup bien sûr parce
que c'est ce qu'il fait si souvent dans
le style d'un du joueur égyptien
d'ailleurs comment s'appellent les
souris à amy a bien passé mais il faut
toujours ce avec le genre de contre qui
que ce soit ce genre d'attaqué est
indienne howey attaqué ce lundi est ce
qu'on appelle qui très souvent le
transpose de les autres vertus à temps
il fallait me propose un truc marrant il
m'a dit de faire ça ok juste pour te
montrer gr g 3g 6 kw est fou g9 g7 et tu
veux faire re 5
oui besson c'est ce qui a été entre eux
dit au monde des échecs dans les années
à la fin des années 80 par toute ma
course et gavrikov de 31-10 en 2d puis
s'est toujours pas réuni les meilleurs
lit pour moi c'est pas du tout une
surprise que meta doute toutes les
villes jouent ça tout les bijoux saint
fabien m'a dit que c'est très malin
camardes de coups parce que tu forçant
un peu des quatre oui bien sûr tu force
avant tous ont défini le scénario
habituel parce que le mec plus ou moins
forcé de jouer des cartes ra la c6 est
donc cette position un peu ennuyeuse
heureusement pour les noirs cette
position and use pour les deux récemment
le noir - les bons aussi en fait parce
que moi je déteste positionne par
exemple on a dit qu'elle a maintenant
une position assez typique pour parents
lorsqu'ils jouent avec les bois ou bien
sûr les bois en donnerait en réussi dans
le virtuel mais de toute façon ce
n'était pas le but
donc qu'est-ce que j'ai réfléchi tour à
celui de gérer sans trop réfléchir
il va faire tout ça se voit cacher sa
balle sur borne normalement ok pour
l'instant sais rien moi je pense qu'à un
moment donné j'aurais ap / m'a touché sa
tour sur cinq par le croate sans aucun
doute ok peut-être devoir faire les deux
fois 6e fois et l'autre de transparence
il a déjà notamment c'est sûrement un
bon avantage c'est clair parce qu'une
fois lors du fou se trouve là c'est
toujours un bon avantage bien sûr parce
que c'est un tel au fou qui est comme un
couteau au cou pour votre gâteau en doré
mais peut-être certains pas du tout dans
vos points de couper votre gâteau nous
avons relié de vous [ __ ] tous les
gâteaux et un flottement
malheureusement il vous reste qu'une
vingtaine est en fait une guerre qui
coûte le gâteau en deux il prend une
part voit justement il est le cas ce
n'est qu'à ce moment il y avait un bois
dire quoi c'est que frère normatif et
toi et tu veux pas donner ça quelqu'un
c'est surtout ok qu'est ce que tu fais
ici que les quatre fois ci pour des
coups très prometteuse ces quatre cas le
secret pour l'instant ça dont moi
j'aurai un mélange rien calculé sans
moment au m34 faut quatre peut-être avec
les des fous du 5 et en que c'est le
cavalier ce cap que les c4 fukada
peut-être intéressant quoique ya besoin
avec les décors les cinq com de com
après que cavaler bouge
non peut-être parce 400mo moyen de voir
si sérieux aucun l'éducateur mais ok
vous sur 2 3 est génial mais vous
convenez sur 2,3 et dévastateur s'il y
arrive donc comme le centre qu'est ce
qu'il va faire et voir beauf ou est joué
4 tu peux tu me l'enlever en fait si tu
vas tu es juste pour vérifier au début
qu'est ce qu'il va faire la maintenance
quatre plus tard pour empêcher ces
quatre autres que je suis passé captifs
et ses quatre intermédiaires attendant
bush qui avait été sa radio à 4 et
cavaliers de ce trou saucisses plutôt
des associations je sais pas je pense
pas que 2,7 et mieux que ceux ci servent
je pense que plutôt ses 6000 enfants à
temps peuvent être à quoi qu ici d'un
bateau que les c6 et attend il ya
peut-être des intermédiaires aussi je le
vois pas à 6 hu
quoique je vois pas qu'est ce que ça
tombe spécialement non plus mais oui
mais y en a tu sais j'ai remarqué
dernièrement j'ai un peu progressé en
blitz
oui j'ai remarqué que c'était hyper
important de faire des intermédiaires
parce que ça énerve
ouais ouais scène il y avait à l'époque
ça a été appelé les méthodes pêcheurs d
attaque et tu vois que toi est ce que tu
penses qu'on peut même bouffer
normalement quand elle beaucoup quand
emilio normalement t'es pas dans la vie
de rentrer dans les complications comme
ça mais moi ce que tu vas marquer un
moment donné peut-être le foot est roi
et peut-être un fléau fourrage 6 mhz
mais je me dis alors fois ci c'était
intéressant mais là il ya cavaliers au
cavalière bouge que vous l'aimez va
quand même prendre lui encore je passe
un hoquet d'amour 3 6 2 3 0 cette fois
je dors un champ d'avocette rouages de
la réserve est atteint même 3,2 et 3,7
non si je veux changer le cours d'eau
de la partie gens si jamais proche d'eux
et quoi est-ce que tactique
ok moi les noirs doivent être mieux
aussi parce que le football au pour à
séoul tam
il va pas participer encore avoir
commencé à continuons donc oui ça c'est
guillaume one élevé offert de fou ça va
faire tout ça et n'a pas regagné 1 piot
mais au moins elle veut quand même que
ces pièces bouge mais qu'attend
matériellement on est où il ya trois
pions les noirs sont un peu mieux
naturellement mais une fois aller au
four sur cette fois ci cela ça va tenir
une autre histoire
donc il faut jouer comme un con qui
concrètement et rapidement si tu aimes
catastrophe se pose c'est tours 4 oui
parce que je veux tour de fonds sera
question que ces trois ça devient dur
hein oui bien sûr donc tout cas très
lourd mais logique à leur tour des trois
tours troyes et tours du oui non et les
bienfaits de couleurs de bouffer tout de
suite elles n'ont pour l'instant joue
bien comme on a joué par servent donc
plutôt tard il est vrai qu il est aussi
fort que ça affreux affreux que ça j'ai
pas en tout cas elle nous a dit que ça
sert à rien qu'ils jouent juste beaucoup
trop fort on est quittes et is off mais
celle dont apparaître à la haye mais les
bombes plus tard elle a ses préférences
personnelles n'avions pas réellement
avoir arrêté des petits clans je ne
parle pas que de ce fait il ne sait pas
donc
ça parle un peu dans le tchad ils nous
disent c'est une masse par hamilton pas
dans le champ de la caméra
alors c'est vrai qu'il a c'est le massif
a besoin sans service voix quand elle
rayonne sur toi c'est amusant alors voté
le transfert que moi que tout le moteur
de la bouverie à ouidah rejettera
compris vous c'est incroyable comme se
prend la voiture vol de voiture
alors on va les mettre qu'on laisse la
fenêtre ouverte que sinon on va juste -
rama yade amos est quand même tiens je
pense notamment cette excuse moi mais si
je fais tour d2 tu menaces pas à et
vient de jeu touré fabien john a oui
donc non autour de deux chasseurs ça
donc non pour l'instant les vautours
sept des huit tours dale et l'est les
besoins de vos penderies
donc s'ils réussissent donc ils doivent
doivent comprendre maintenant qu'est-ce
que je veux le faire oui layle d'un
empire quand donc dans ce 3 si je me
trompe pas est tout à fait possible
il menace échanger les dents après quoi
rien ne va sauver le moteur des cabots
donc peut-être encore une dame d'être
adamo 5 dans le 5/7 6/2
pourquoi de nos côtes
moi j'irai demain 6h 7h quatre noms ne
sais pas pourquoi je pense qu'il verse à
qui le force 3 bon oui donc ces trois
fois je crois tout ce qu'il faut aux six
abandons donc maintenant c'est les noirs
qui doivent choisir quoi offrir
exactement plus d'interdît 6,5 ont
protégé le point m6 howe est peut-être
quelque chose comme ça qu'est ce que ce
serait bien de changer les dames
mais si dans le sens qu'il va sûrement
pas échangé la danse fois thouars 500
sur la tête
ici dans le sens que dans deux sens
je suppose qu'une fois je suppose c'est
bien ça c'est logique mais force 3 et 5
déjà c'est une réussite parce que les
cases noires donc peut-être bon ben je
passe de imagination maintenant je joue
plus haut depuis trois ans mais plutô t
d était ok donc ces doses de 2 x 3 5 kg
et adam
la balle est donc dommage 6 par exemple
tu va attaquer le plonger si je sois sur
six points sur son grand chose
oui je sens que c'est plus beau nom pour
l'instant le joue comme moi je sais quoi
je dois dire pour l'instant notre jour
comme j'aime bien dire d'une manière
fischer est là maintenant d'ailleurs
abandonné même ce tour sur deux sets
parce que les noirs en quatre pions des
jeunes
ouais mais généralement ils ont menacé
même pas un truc genre ces deux mêmes
des trucs comme d'emprunt 3 alors quand
même pas parce que tu aimes système
solidaire beau mais c'est fait par
contre ces deux fois soit tous trois
étaient possibles sur pause oui je pense
que c'était possible
oui mais pour quoi s'offrir la tête si
sur france 3 et 4 qu'est ce que au
niveau du détendeur 12 secondes contre
31,1 et le mal partout ailleurs ok
m'avait coûté l'ouverture
ok l'attaqué stade il n'est pas si
mauvaise mais comment d'aller prêter ce
poème daddy g 3 3 et 2 ans d'entretien
par un fil à main sur trois et un agenda
magique à damas je mate aussi je reçois
tout d'un terrain au territoire donné ok
je dois être un
le monstre ou saratov en prouve qu il y
dîne défaveur de l'est via le web donc
d4 que les 6 je pense que par jour
souvent la grippe a cette fois ci si je
comprend bien son style elle doit faire
échec sur le cac c'est plus ou moins sûr
parce que c'est bien son style et les
rebords luigi sonel camp
ça lui demande si ça va et plus
talentueux que fuir ou de la non je m'en
doute hockey dans le jour de ses ravages
j'ai pas vu une seule partie encore où
ça a été vraiment spécial vous voyez ce
que je veux dire ce pré show comme les
américains dits spéciaux je préviens
sous le par tandis que délicat de faire
usage pour une fois je vais youtube si
quelqu'un or comment quoi tu penses il
va être champion du monde un genre à
l'eau c'est trop tôt de dire c'est trop
tôt de dire parce que devenir champion
du monde se tait loi de circonstance
tellement du boulot c'est tellement dur
de la force psychologique c'est
tellement de choses tant de choses en
fait que pour l'instant rien à dire il
est archi des personnes sans doute mais
trop de dire quoi que ce soit je ne pas
commencer rien après tout cette position
là par contre je pense pas que de
s'inquiéter oublie que toi pourquoi pas
tous bords et juste parce que si tu
joues rondes normalement quelques jours
l'un comment s'appellent les structures
carlsbad la tam est mal passée surtout 3
donc ce n'était pas la peine de se
dépêcher de la chasse est justement ce
poids du tout la parole à peine juste
tour bruit des os qui est du pur de
toute manière il va se casser méchant
qui pensent qu'ils jouent avec ses 5
oui mais je vais faire dix heures isolé
photo c dr tachi en grand spécialiste du
point isolé n'aime pas trop ban dont ce
pas pour ici quoi se joue pas pour ici
locaux à 4 souligne la faute
mais qu'est ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant tu te rappelles y avait une
interview un petit peu spatiale de par
am qui disait qui bosse et les échecs 20
heures par jour qu'il avait besoin de
personne pour l'aider et plus ou moins
qui allait devenir très bientôt champion
du monde se rappelle de sa oui bien sûr
je les palio en fait qu'à terme en
europe par les cétacés spatiale c'est
bien spéciale
et lui au cours de ces deux parties -
turquie ont peut-être inventé on a
dépassé avant normal pour le mec moigne
deux de passer son temps avant de créer
un nouveau mais à peine oui peut-être
mais quoique maintenant les noirs bon ok
c'est bon c'est bon en fait non je veux
pas critiquer il joue bien ça encore
l'idée c'est que si les noirs jouent
d'investissement yaka valeo 5 qui
mouille les pressions a directement sur
2,5 with sûr c'est surtout ça oui ici
tous rêvent de 8,4 et déjà plus de
courant fait donc tu peux pas jouer à
cette position normale puisque pas de
quoi en fait je marchais cela oui quoi
faire juste jeu on se demande donc et
non routier se trouvant au km2 cerrato
vo dire que ce film est pour le
soviétique mais ne bon c'est pas pour
ici pour justement parce que je sens
comme le sens de drastiques beaucoup
plus fort aya kanno cinq de nos 10 4
qu'est ce qu'une excuse excusez moi ok
c'est excusable pour quelqu'un qui joue
plus depuis trois ans non non excusez
moi je me trompe mais quand les deux
jeunes femmes
je pense que c'est bien trop beau pour
être vrai donc maintenant ok donc non
mais c'est bien je g5 à rien car déjà
elle doit jouer pour l'espoir
tiens intéressant ça c'est bien vrai
hymne à skis et prendrait 5
plutôt oui si aucun coin que les noirs
ou de droit de jeu que les six parce que
carlos encore les taux devraient donc
encore joué olivier c'est justement leur
offrir les trois écoles et 80 si jamais
donc aux kings
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont ce genre de son
faon là on est quand même beaucoup plus
première nous les
le rotrou livia oui car les 2 3 des
recettes mais qui en vaut il veut tout
protéger quoi en gros je pense que
normalement les bancs ont perdu leur
avantage après l'ouverture
donc maintenant c'est le jour interne
homme comme on appelait ça qu'est ce que
je fais ce que je peux prendre et ça
colle et c5 damas de damas deux bons jo
bouche ou de ce tu vas prendre prendre
et prendre 6 on peut juste celui plus
facile fou de cette qualité 4 4 après
plus trois comme ça entre 5 et 10 6
je dois dire que d'après ce que je sais
sur les deux je pense que comment ces
rames doivent viser davantage de
l'ouverture parce que je pense que c'est
une faiblesse dans le judo parents te
dire qu'ils travaillent pas assez pour
l'instant pour quelques-uns parmi nous
[Rires]
pour quelques génial d'aller le voir et
le rôle des parm les portes et arbres
il faut quand même plus je suppose que
c'est facile de thiviers qu'est ce qu'il
fait les restants 14 euros je croise il
faut pas être un il faut pas trop tarder
pour eux
devinez ce qu'il faut et le reste du
temps déjà me d'obligations donc en a
commencé avec gambeat audi a6 et là d'un
coup on s'est retrouvé dans un jardin
est ce lundi entre un fils de troisième
fleuve 4 troisième fois je sens que ma
vie avec un cadre que les six que les
trois et six fours je sens que typique
pour ce système
oui bizarre les rebondissements donc dis
moi qu'est ce que tu fais ici d'ailleurs
de nouveau je préfère les bons parce que
je te tester le fou comme le surjeu
cette majorité c'est faux on ne peut
plus faire c'est 5 et mettre la pression
c'est horrible mais d'un autre côté
non je préfère largement les blancs en
fait tu vas faire h4 d'un match 5 un
jour elle sait pas mais je déteste de
telles chaussures je sais pas ce qu'il
me rappelle moi me c'est à dire bah
disons que toute ma vie je joue aux
échecs oui j'arrive pas à faire une
autre chose où j'arrive pas ouais donc
si vous deviez six mois c'est fou je
sais tu le pion du catrc les échecs pour
moi si tu peux rien rien d'autre
coquio de die hard et autre chose dans
la vie donc plus au boulot mais je vais
jamais les attendre peut-être d'amd ans
même sans faire l'impasse sur moi mais
moi je suis presque sûr le public à la
maison qui est bien protégé par les
crues
d'ailleurs bien protégé donc c'est pas
pour moi je le dise un truc original
genre damage synchro h deux tours h au
hall à laquelle concept et qu'est ce que
ce beau culot cavrot assurage docile à
protéger pour le coup sûr je crois qu'il
a sans ce dernier en fait h4 brand un
bon avantage des bois c'est sûr mais
maintenant il faut être précis parce que
le mec veut donc compliqué de choses
après 4 oui donc là maintenant il faut
être précis et trouver le coup
normalement au kef des six oui mais
c'est fini c'est fini
pourquoi pas ouvrir à parce que
peut-être levé le mot tu es sur
collonges
je pense que ça irait aussi vite que ça
mais il en faut pas beaucoup pour
réussir ça il va jamais il va jouer
parce que moi j'ai fait tous rêvent de 8
avec le défenseur assure se sentir après
deux vidéos et audio roue qu'est ce que
j'aurais fait des petits faisaient
fréquemment caisse il faut 5 et vous
ferez mouvement donc oui oui oui caisse
à ses fans russes quoi ça se voit 200 km
sans nous donc il est il blanc quoique
fausse en 2007 il est pas mal par hasard
ce 4e tome de son président monsieur
gilles trequesser
c'est typique typique et n'importe quel
mac os n'importe quelle est encore en
apporter quelques semis leurs forces et
à tous du sud auquel avait pas foncé
qu'à terme de cinq ans tu vois pas
brader quoi
aulas je pourrais vous désole le maire
de saratov n'a pas vu au sens non plus
c'est joli ça c'est joli personne n'a vu
venir aux nîmois donc elle valait donc
elle va perdre mais parce que quoi
d'autre sauf aux enfants autour d'un
tour dans le passé
ok avec les malheureusement et 6 pouces
il devait faire tout reprend ses quatre
salles bien que les soucis très agréable
à machin rock et damas sont donc faibles
3 rookie russe russe n'est pas bon il
préfère dames des jeux sandy que foot et
si c'était un très maigre et un dessin
qui avait quand même droit je suis très
calme très bienvenu de la part de femmes
ouais ouais ouais ok pour le blitz bien
sûr mais bien sûr et les bornes internet
- mieux de toute violence matin est
encore un problème sur la colonne h non
non mais les hyper précis au québec pour
bouffer beau c est ok on peut commencer
la troisième attaque aux parents qu'il
faut degré mois soleil chaos
olivier c'est bien ça qu'est-ce qu'il
est fort ricard ou en blitz
ouais si red bull d'avoir pensé reese
était aussi fort que vous juste pour du
vent sur le deuxième baquet ce qu'il ya
de mieux pour l'oubli ce que la ville
est vraiment fort mais dis moi et ce
comme son adversaire voit les grimoires
cible s'il veille peu oui je pense que
vaut mieux de ne pas garder ça parce que
ce doit être très heureux ici fait en
fait ils chantent
oui il chanta y en a qu à murat
peut-être est lui aussi mais tu connais
peut-être pailladins caméra non pardon
ayana camurat tu connais pas c'est une
chanteuse je te ferai découvrir
ok donc plus de cas va lire trois
étoiles il aime à auxerre ok ok nous
voulions interversion de l'éthique la
mahatma bien sûr potro raconte tout le
monde fou deux petits rouges à deux là
des questions oui baissier je trouve
plus intéressant quand même parce que
ici c'est pas très très intéressant pour
le voir parce que le noir / jour un
petit peu moins bien jeter le parti dans
un opéra d'horreur je pense que je joue
et des qataris et avec les blancs et le
make up adoubé 6 donc
je les tortures est finalement apte à
gagner je gagne ma gaieté bon ok 2460
pas ses mots ça m'a pris beaucoup de
temps de gagner mais j'étais ça pour le
noir j'aime pas ça en fait le problème
les gars c'est que quand les bois on
veut le faire en double file enquêtes
vont mieux que si les noirs vieux jeu
avec ses 6 2 5 du mieux qu'ils le noir
réussissent à jouer cavalier ou quatre
pour que les barrages ou des cadres et
brooke le canada parce que si le monde
malheureusement les noirs égalise pas
normalement les d'où l'idée de fab de
faire gérer cette guerre parce que la
mettre là non c'est ce doit être un
petit peu mieux pour les bourgs qu'elle
est maintenant offerte ou 8 maintien ça
c'est très concret très bien sûr forgé
cette nouvelle peut-être les trous et
trois étaient légèrement apprécié parce
que là maintenant que vous avez 3 à ses
chiens il faut admettre et ses chiens et
trouvera faire aussi fou g4 dans 17 et
attaquer le roi n'a donc je 4h 3
mettaient pas sur qui tu veux ou fausse
trois s'opposent mais que valent et de
3,7 déjà ses chiens qu'est ce qu'il doit
faire maintenant
[ __ ] territoire juste parce que 5
c'est quand même assez fort puis ça ne
savons que le fouet
donc trois camions pour casser la chaîne
de piau mme fehr f4 comme les 2 3 et 5
hier il a fait mais est-ce que ça résolu
le problème quand parce que je vois pas
où ça mène à présent je vois pas l'aider
parce que s'ils allaient aux cavaliers
sur detroit contre les gaz f4f de tu vas
jamais doublé le tour euh ok oeuvre
c'est pour égaliser
fc pour ok je veux pas une grosse
bataille je veux juste égaliser et
recommencer avec les bas quoique fosse 3
je trouve assez bizarrement je n'ai fait
que trois accords les foyers avaient
forcé auquel elle rêve compris ok ok
mais ça est ce que c'est vraiment un
gardien dont je pense pas que quelqu'un
le meilleur ici comme nous pas ok non je
pense ce doit être ça doit tourner
autour du pot de terre auquel avons
maintenant elle va faire d'un mode à
l'autre voire frères touré veut huit de
trash 5 à un moment donné ok plus ou
moins de guerre met donc un pied noir
champion isoler la après d'un modèle
d'ailleurs il va donc de traces il faut
puisque tout référée dans vos 5 300 par
contre c'est un coup à se finir je pense
que les deux ont des tendances de trop
faire l'écho finiens mais je pense que
ça ce que font les différences entre eux
des cas c'est ce que craint
n'importe quelle position jeu très très
très concrètement
concrètement par coup par coup pas juste
iannuzzo qui ont ouvert tout ce que l'on
sait mais ouverte jumelles et oui mais
puisque dans le bon sens je pense que ça
a été un coup très très intéressant car
on n'ose pas puisque si le mec a un
point faible sur des 5 tu veux changer
rien sur elle mais j'ai l'impression est
que mais il ya une grosse différence de
niveau en tout cas entre le speech est
junior et le speech est adulte c'est
énorme et c'est tous ces petits détails
la presse et tous ces petits coups oui
parce que ça ce que fait la différence
en un terrain joueur d'élite et ajustant
très très fort y'a pas de quoi finir et
il n'existe juste pas de tels cours est
gardé par exemple partir de 10 ans ils
purent se tromperait ils purent mal joué
mais il va jamais faire un coup juste
une colonne s'est mis au vert du meeddat
aux anneaux à chaque fois se justifie
reparler calculer comment tu fais pour
passer
et du niveau très fort quand m au niveau
grand maître d'élite assez normal tout
commence à moment donné d'affronter des
joueurs très forts et tu obtiens des
bons position et je gagne quoi et tu
gagnes pas tu girl power et un moment
donné tu te demandes pourquoi est-ce que
je vais pas et les conclusions ne
renonce pas et la halle qu'on continue à
progresser tout change parce que tu
comprends si tout continue à faire comme
avant
tu vas jamais passé le k tu vas jamais
battu en 2007 m
de ce pas de 1704 si tu as les tendances
jusqu'où je peux faire que les quatre
victoires les bleus n'ont pas d'aidé
mais bien sûr les brandes rêve km les
bruits les airs que vous envoie
s'appartient pas cette position même si
le roi faible l'euro adversaires comme
le rouble a battu on a fait les
prophéties contre les choses autant
d'inconvénients mais c'est doit être
hyper dur de passer de ce niveau à ce
niveau non oui c'est beaucoup de travail
surtout psychologique parce que comme
vous savoir par exemple un moment donné
c'était un problème dans le zou totem en
or je pense
il ne réussissait pas de gagner des
pressions gagnante contre les plus
fleuris et il a demandé le conseil de
bouts de vie ni qu'est ce que je dois
faire et votre famille que l'audi a6
doit justement m pas joué ouais pour ne
pas faire court le couteau sud
d'ailleurs vous écrivez parfois qui vous
mêmes et annick d'autrui je pense que
mes anecdotes manquait quelques joueurs
par exemple une énigme à moins que
peut-être parfois les premiers chiffres
mais mais c'est dommage je peux bien
celle un tel talent d'ailleurs qu'est-ce
qu'il a mérité son dernier tournoi après
+3 c'est un vrai melting non
donc psychologiquement et un problème
une fois ils commencent de voir des
problèmes dans les parties dans le
tournoi ça y est c'est comment s'appelle
la chute
ouais la descente il ajouté.le avait
comme mauvais atterrissage pas comme
dans la forêt du coup les noirs se
retrouve de nouveau pas trop mal parce
que la tour ces deux et pas très bien
non
ok il pouvait pas jouer aux livres 4
parce qu'à jouer au qatar gagnait 1 mt 4
fou de 14 heures locales et de huawei
écoutez je pense quand même que c'est
rama est plus fort dans les blitz
classique
juste parce qu'il est plus de bagage
culturel comme on dit mais je sais pas
qui est ce qui va arriver dans les
boulettes
après il rien il n'a pas encore gagné
cela n'aurait il pas sur ça elle va
gagner parce que déjà c'est pas trop dur
on va voir
c'est pas trop dur ce même basique en
quelque sorte tu gagnes 500%
contre n'importe qui ok ok sinon je sais
pas gramatois rage au grain contre
compte une compagne et de fisher
kasparov capot foccart sert douce réunis
et avec eux comment s'appelle avec elles
choisiront en ligne je crains qu'un tour
de 700 à réfléchir autour de 7 et qui
est ce que tu fous bien ok c'est pas
mauvais bien sûr mais tours de 7 ses
blindés toi tu veux plan des noms de
doter une position quant à d'opium de
plus mathématiquement parce que tu as
donné ta de plus c'est tout blanc c'est
tout ce que tu intéressante c'est tout
ce qui est intéressant
tu parles depuis tu commences de
progresser tous les positions mais tu
lèves tu les f-5 au fc 3 1 6 mhz
ok c ca sert a fait ses premières mais
là c'est facile
ok là maintenant elle veut crier du
contre jour ou à la fixant les pylônes à
cette bêtise
quoiqu'il les questions comment elle
veut utiliser pascal keller par jour b 5
pour scotcher la tour sur laquelle on
dit ça j'ai pas aimé du tout je pouvais
arriver à ces retours de 205 qui mollit
dojo bizarre mais quand qui quand donc
l'occasion de christian papillon passer
de cris des fans je vous tue fouet puis
tu lis tu tu le prends comme étudiant
ses cinq as fait c'est bizarre non comme
choix attends je vais avec l'ordi ses
parents n'en avait aucune raison
ok les représentants de l'ancienne école
n'approuve pas le choix des brames de
noix là maintenant de nouveau c'est
complètement gagnant bien sûr
fellag et une manière assez soupçonnant
puisque d'après vous prend à 7 c'était
peut-être plus si simplement tout mais
peut-être il a juste oublié le pur style
ce il faut pas chercher trouvant que tu
attends il ya juste oublir auquel est
abandonné 2,1
donc maintenant
c'est intéressant et dites moi
d'ailleurs mes amis de la chanson
quelqu'un que parmi vous qui connaît qui
est le leur comment dire qui est plus
fort selon vous à vos boulettes
on peut déjà regardé leur classement
2008 145 pour parham 2837 le zoo avec
les libraires un donc c'est vraiment un
favori pas présent ok là maintenant
parents me rendrai dans les variantes
rosaire qui au il adore moi j'aime
beaucoup analysé cette variante l'a
d'ailleurs je connais pas mal de choses
ici intéressant les queues à quel point
c ran à canet tout ça maintenant le cool
ou plus ont répondu à ces caveaux
l'histoire comme les c6 est rien du tout
bien sûr et là c'est bizarre par contre
parce que parents jouent ça très très
souvent avec les noirs et il le faut
nous préparer comme ça parce que cavale
et ses six co 2 3 bien sûr c'est un
principe déjà 6 x 4 et sculpteo bouffer
sur requête fawcett que vous l'êtes de
foot de 8,8 pas dans ce cas là pourquoi
la foire 6 dieu le sait appartient
bizarre non les deux joues mal foutu
trois petits rôles je sais mais bizarre
on a introduit à cause de l'air
maintenant elle va jouer quoique réussi
ce tour de vue moi qui me colle et de
7,7 tellement bizarre dans cette
position là pourquoi il avait besoin de
tout ça qui kovalev six fours trois
tours 12e quatre peut-être je suppose
il va pas faire grande rocade
normalement les noirs veulent pas faire
prendre de nouvelles positions
d'après mes connaissances me tour 2004
celui ci
question quoique peut-être y est de 5,5
euros le 4 mai ça va perdre donc voilà
attend blague pour régis meyrinois
raison quoi ils ont un pion arriérés en
d6 au résumé est ok grïngo c'est une
s'est institué un signe qui s'était pas
parfait quoi là maintenant elle va faire
tour de 3,41
c'est pas énorme mais grande roue que
normalement c'est un signe que quelque
chose n'a pas aller trop bien non
seulement il doit plutôt être là
justement
n'oublions pas les siciliens et criez
pas pour que tu t'es ok quand même
pourquoi nos amis parce que quel
avantage de bandol et cécilia
philosophique ma parole c'est au début
où les ventes à jo d'hiver dopés
après et cambrai surtout les avantages
de l'espace et les noix compte sur un
pion de plus de le centre et sur la
colonne s'est ouverte que les colonnes
si nous versaient mais le problème c'est
que lorsque vous vous recueillir l'eau
vous avez un problème de utiliser les
colons c'est ça le problème est là
maintenant les brand vont donc pressé
sur des six bouger les pions sur l'ailé
droit donc tour des trois tours 2 et 4 4
dans le milieu il noir doit retrouver
qu'est ce qu'il veut faire
ok la montagne propose alors de rentrer
dans la française
ok je sais pas si elle a lieu de ici
n'ont qu'à voler le deuxième coussin 4
euros a droit à
car leur évite que les 2 4 et tu veux
dire mon canton je sais pas sûr que sans
qu'ils étaient si bons puisque en fait
je pense que cette française de
l'acceptable donc 2,5 était bien joué je
sens que je sais pas sur eux sans
peut-être eu des cas pourquoi pas aux
données d'être comme plus simple le jeu
se passe bien pour les plans plutôt que
je me trompe il est possible mais je me
donne je me demande juste si je vais
réussir à faire faux bon sens est-ce que
ça va être beaucoup pour toi ok bien moi
je ramassais les baies 3 à 4 ok je joue
dans mon sang je fais damas 5
oui je veux trouver ça oui je veux jouer
au faux besoins ou x 4 peut totalement
mon tour à ça j'ai pensé dans koh 6-3
non en fait ce que je veux faire cécile
et la rocaille vont servir à boire aux
abois nombreuses jour on apprend
toujours
cette dame b 3 je les collais virus
peut-être dans métro non jamais jamais
le russe pour jouer tant que trois alors
ce qu'on va faire voir bois ou doit
autour d'un lot de les autres coûts
évidemment pas aidé c'est sûr il n'a
même pas regardé
[Musique]
ok il est vrai t'as raison élevé au foot
la tour sur les troisièmes aussi doté 3
6 3 pour 3 quelque chose comme ça donc
les mots de passe et apparemment de 10,6
des caisses qu'il va contredire ce point
est donc bien sûr pas b3 parce que ça
bloque la touriste a bouclé troisième
pour le retour donc x 4
qu'attend il menaçait 2 mais génial
comment ce parti se déroule c'est
intéressant c'est intéressant parce que
c'est le clash de deux approches c'est
toujours intéressant parce que chacun a
ses atouts et linois on leur colle on
sait qui il s'est quand même d'utiliser
les points on
au fond le cavalier sur des quatre qui
déchire et donc comme les faiblesses des
cases en noir autour du roi noir
je pense que quand même libre ans
doivent servir l'argent mais de longs
mois pas largement je préfère le mot
d'ordre est toujours pris les blancs
mais c'est parce que tu joues pas les
françaises je joue bien la française
avec les blancs nerfs j'ai le très bon
résultat
j'aime bien faire le plein dans le deuil
une fois pain en que tu joues au coach
qui obtient de très bons résultats lors
des 4 6 1
car il essaie de l'éviter paris
tenteront postive d'accord t'as fait des
quatre cavaliers f6 tafer des quatre des
cinq fois f4 et ils font des 4,6 y y en
a deux médailles d'or qui récompense qui
lui est tantôt parce qu'ils n'ont mais
en fait on trouve tout ce qui est très
évolué parce que je fais des quatre
dessins des quatre cavaliers fils rouges
et 5 décembre
cavaillé des deux bords à l'âge d'or
mais c'est assez évolués comme truc qui
ont cru en maintenant alors géré jef
peut-être dans votre roi ou à boire pour
ce 3ème stratus entre celui d'un peu de
sérieux non qu'il faut oui j'aimerais
bien ces places 1k mariage sans qu'un
manga d'impôt quatre noms pour le moins
ça marche pas c'est du bailleur d'arbres
4 c'est dans le milieu
cette tour des 3 pendant le banquet les
question c'est comment est-ce que tu
view déménager matour mammadzade apa 14
il est très bien passé là parce que roy
budo qu il ya quatre mois me sinon il ya
tête je puis dire et qui sait si c'est
chaque oui mais c'est pas ambitieux mais
c'est pas bizarre non mais peut-être il
faut déjà eu tout faux c'est si atos et
sis tout ceci est faux c'est si sedan b
si tu menaces précises un roi bien
j'aime pas dans des cas très commedia
quatre ans terry leahy dans le cadre du
bien sûr d'un bébé gaza vient encore
plus fort j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont
on sera tous fauchés qui glisse à
défendre le bâti c'est très ruska proxy
derrière on vit dans une société
tellement patriarcale et à schalke une
fois il s'agit de pape sy un philippe
loup c'est vrai d'ailleurs ça a été
toujours ma phobie ce faire c'est vrai
c'est pour ça qu'il fait sur des
chantiers tôt tu fais des petits kremlin
devant quoi le petit crime vol ce qui en
fait en russie il y apprendra
discourtois cré maurice et dans toutes
les grandes villes russes il y avait
cinq sessions il ya foule 5 fu bo 5 et
d'un produit non faussée et je fais
quelque chose d'autre peut-être je fais
qu avait laissé quatre fosses eu quatre
décès avec les 2 3 parce que c'est plus
agréable et avec les noirs je suppose
n'oubliez pas de plans sur ce cadre il
est à chier désagréable parce que c'est
ce qu'ont appris les tensions favorables
ou et un choisi kampf est sûr b3 choisi
comme jouer ce coin et un choisi caen ne
rien faire du tout autant elle n'y a pas
cavalier à 4 annonc é à quatre ils
protègent la dame hulu bien joué et bien
joué il n'y a qu'à titre au ceram à dos
bon c'est bon c'est bon
300 que cette prophétie musulmane donc
qu'est ce qu'il va faire maintenant
il a sûrement beaucoup trop d'émanations
prime 5 mais s'y coller des six que vous
il ya quatre ans
comment ok donc en fait il n'y a pas de
favori dans ce match c'est très très
très équilibrée et par rio pour nous
améliorer
chers amis tant mieux pour nous c'est un
clash de style en quelque sorte oui là
l'imagination diot mec vingt sur vingt
quatre et l'école en pots cassés diu
différemment à temps mais peut-être ça
tient encore qualité six tours à sanguin
b 6 mai mais qu'est ce que tu veux bien
qu un nombre que les quatre dames saint
lô l'estrac et citoyens damas de m ok là
le meneur de jeu il est en gros ont vite
abandonné parce qu'il ya pas trop en
fait l'eau le cobra au caire mais ses
larges
ok mais ça c'est l'âge oui il est il est
jaune il il est encore des illusions
qu'est ce que vous voulez - moissonnage
devrait pas toutefois contre qui tu vois
sauvé sa contrefaçon en fait contre ton
membres
non mais je reviendrai pas assez morte
mais baissé dans laquelle m bernaquez
quoi tout ce qu'il peut remarquer ici
c'est l'opium h
c'est tout ce qu'il peut remarquer dans
cette position rien d'autre ok mais
regarde l'autre réfléchie mais mal
autant non ok ce jour ce qu'il réfléchit
rentrer dans cette finale après dans ce
sens pour trouver comment recoller à 4-4
[Musique]
ok ok 4 bien joué bien jouer sang-froid
comme les c3 24 dans des huit roy s'est
fait d'abord mon goût c'est bien trop
créatif de ses sa a acquis elvis de
hockey pourquoi pas mais qui tout ce que
vous voulez gagner deux ou trois gains
voilà ce temps d'abandonner ce qui est
arrivé bon dodo annoncé chaud qu'un
match c'est très intéressant comme
athlète au kenya 3 2 3 ce que très très
très et les mots ces derniers temps là
sauf que personne aux justices
énormément aux caisses et kata les
modèles offerts faut 2 et andré
montrealimentaires rentrer dans un type
de variantes schlechter de la soif
sauf que le biome se trouve sur 2 ou
encore ce que don qui cause des hoquets
je préfère toujours les voir mais pour
qui il faut dire que j'aime bien qu'en
grand chelem campagne arrive sur quatre
hectares fait ça je trouve que ça va
toujours plus ou moins de toute manière
je préfère le fou surgit 3 par rapport
aux faux sur deux à vrai dire je trouve
que les mieux sur g3 qui se rebelle âgé
de tuer sur le deuil le mieux que sur
deux
du coup dans le chat on nous signale
qu'il y ait quatre victoires noir c'est
vrai qu'on n'a pas on n'a pas fait le
rapprochement mais pendant que les noirs
gagne mais je pense que c'est le cas
souvent dans cette compétition là parce
que dans cette compétition mère sauf que
choque parfois personne ne veuille
montrer des grosses des dents les
émotions ok il y avait fait parfois car
ces notions par exemple dès le moi je
compte dessus que les montres et des
gosses des idées dans les airs sur par
exemple la première fois que quelqu'un
d'élite a joué que vale de quatre colis
6-4 1-6 kovalev 3 200 que les trois à
six ça a était carson dans ce type de
match compte que shu l'itf
oui et puis après tout le monde a
commencé deux jours ça dans la pratique
classique donc mais normalement tout le
monde daily de montrer leur grosse
préparation parce que telle et les
proches pour l'oubli de ce présent
conquois sais pas trop sérieux à quoi ça
sert de montrer les ouvertures
remplissent même si ce fonds ne vis plus
sérieux que les partis classiques non ça
devrait leur arrivée dans bliss les
préparations des ouvertures n'est pas
moins important sur qui ont de la
compétition classiquement pas du tout
d'ailleurs peu regarde
qu'est-ce que par ahmad au lieu de trois
le fond noir sur deux trois ans que je
joue avec les bons choix seul à faire
des princes et si cela oui mais si
l'ombre aux compensations
je sais mais tu dois faire entre laval
et ses six tours boujdour sweet est
inquiet mais j'aurais pas les simples
sont des cinq ans vit quand même
non mais oui je préfère comme on joue
comme ça ok bien sûr les rien
objectivement - au moins de laisser ce
que ma part déjà les questions ou
maintenant cavalier pascaline qui menace
tout prend prises dans ces trois oui
sinon menacé silhouettes ont collé sur
ce sens ok et surtout prendre des
chemins de fer qui prend b2 non
peut-être fou 84 des trois noms matin
faut que tu fais trucage fait des trois
fosses tron
je suis très content et je suis très
content très content non tu peux pas
normalement et tu peux pas faut beau
symbole
il faut quatre à sept mille fois mille
mille fois mieux parce que lolo vous
appartient pas ce canal
il n'est pas bien mais si je passe du
trophée et te faire dame c5 ici et si tu
prends je prends deux baies et j'essaye
d'être un pourtour baer ne pense pas que
ça va pas te donner chose je pense que
tu peux essayer de viser un peu plus que
cela
moi je pense que je vais faire qu'est ce
que j'aurais fait ici que d'autres
cavaliers 105 bougies ce que voulait t4
je pense que ça a été intéressante parce
qu'ici blessés que voulez vous sentirez
plus être un problème parce que dans ce
but si ce que vous laisse coi et je
menace que les 284 n'importe quoi d'être
aussi ce genre d'avis at mp non t'as pas
le droit d'en laure de calcul si vite
tu peux te faire prendre un contrôle
antidopage c'est que ça ils trient
surtout trois paires rethel sur 1,8
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont d'ailleurs
souvent une faiblesse chez les joueurs
classiques russes
c'est qu'une fois les positions des
régionales les blancs il ya un problème
est un problème avec toutes les forces
qui l'ont ils essaient de rendre les
positions classiques tandis que les
positions des régionales il faut les
traiter autrement les positions
originales
il faut traiter de manière régionale
tu peux pas les traiter on s'en doute
l'école rien de regarder il a déjà donné
le plus de recettes
l'autre mais le beauf pas non plus
écoutez mes amis il a pas vus il a raté
ça je pense que moi bon forme
donc qu'est-ce que
plus haut maintenant bien sûr mais à la
grande époque qui les regarde je pense
qu'il est pas comme j'ai la burqa ce
n'est pas une grand chose à voir avec
l'agriculture façon récurrente et ce à
la grande époque ou pas oui largement ça
fait pas pour eux est même repassée
fabriqué moi par contre derrière moi
demain ils ont rentré quand ils ont
réussi leur entrée dans une position
plus ou moins typique normal je pense
que le noirmont aucun problème est
peut-être un petit peu mieux ne pas
beaucoup parce que ok ils ont un super
fou sur scène tout défendu le covan est
sûre budo est archi bizarre mais une
fois qu'ils bougent le pion sur le sac
de terreau à jour leur intérêt peut
offrir plus je pense que tintin si les
noirs sont un petit peu mieux même pas
beaucoup en fait je pense que ça tourne
autour de l'égalité de 4-4
ça va être à lyon buzzer il est
tellement bizarre
owen wilson en moi je pense que les
noirs sont mieux h 5 h 4 29 millions à
quel point marqué et en version noire
maintenant les noms les bleus doivent
deux doivent tâche 5 comprendre
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire avec la la
crise impose qu est gaza lycée bienvenue
parce que surtout france échec de
personnes menacées force 3 à quoi la
mode a par contre les noirs sont
nettement mieux parce qu'ils vont
obtenir le contrôle de l'éco l'on sait
et qu'est ce que ça veut dire le
contrôle sur le cancer circ une fois la
tour va arriver sur ces deux les très
probables de perdre l'un des cavaliers
qui on était placée d'une manière
exemplaire sur buzz 2 auquel est
maintenant il va faire quoi qu à l'épée
3f 6,8 au laquelle façon drastique
peut-être qu'ils aient raison d'un epr
il a pris il était très jeune un
exception la miellée millau bien sûr
mais moi j'aurais pensé nos trois fois
avant d'avoir prendre il a joué presque
tempo tête le juste m'intéressant à la
tombe à la pendule là par contre x 3
puis à force d'âme j'ai trois échecs qui
doivent hésiter entre ça et dames g3
direct mesdames et 3 dans le set
qu'est ce que c'est que ce à quoi
pourquoi ils ont pris sur eux ce trader
fait un truc non franchement gagné le
truc tout ce qu'il faut voir et faire
que du hockey les noirs sont toujours
mieux
du coup tu comprends pourquoi le fichier
acheminant les plus intéressants de
sexiste était sexiste d'ailleurs ok on
sait très bien qu'ils s'appellent
misogyne mais ceux qui sont comment dire
à mon féminin
non mais je veux dire que ceux qui
dénigrent les mecs il s'appelle comment
ok je sais qu'il ya un mois je les
connais et je me rappelle pas donc tu
dois te prie comores short misogyne et
toi tu es qui mit en dresser sa mise en
examen qui vise le besoin de noms mais
justement tu joues pour le titre c'est
vrai que c'est comment s'appelle ce qui
dénigre les mets que junior minimise
inde qui dénie comment ceux qui aiment
les mecs junior ceux qui dénigrent
ok ok c'est bien sûr complètement foutu
pour les blancs val c'est sûr et c'est
sûr ah oui mais pourquoi il les photos
de toi le lait quand même que spontanée
mais pourquoi tout ça tout ça c'est ce
qu'ont préparé dans sa salle pour cette
phobie des idiots serre la main de
l'adversaire
non mais ça n'est quand même pas rien
quand même là non non non pas qu pas
fermée mais il va revenir et à tour sur
péno libre en ont bien mérité de pire
dans cette date il un mois que te ça va
pas se produire
ok mais il a plus de temps il a plu à 70
euros 2 il a plu à 7 ans ok ok ok à
chaque fois j'oublie les points d'une
place pour ça qu'il veut vite en fait
c'était pour tuer à la pendule bond de
3,2 si je me trompe pas et grande
couronne les noirs on gagne cinq
victoires c'est quand même un peu
beaucoup pour respirons alors que les
nous avons gagné toutes les parties
jusqu'à la fin dans trois c'est un coup
très très très étriqué je connais
pourquoi week-end mais page que vous
avouer le secret parce qu'il est plus un
secret mais en fait elle le problème
c'est quoi le problème c'est qu'ils sont
mauvais parce que après tout que cinq ou
six les banques jouent aussi dans nos 6
à 4 est sur b4 et acolyte de 5 d'android
requêtes saisies d'armes et 3,3 points
d'exclamation c'était des 25 tours ça et
c'est un gros problème pour le mois je
peux l'avouer maintenant passer parce
que c'est toujours ce matin une pièce de
moins pour les blancs et les noirs
vampire de cette question viendra vous
bien ce jeu là vous puisque s'était
montré récemment partie bruni là je
pense avant l'une des filles et il ya un
an et demi ou deux ans peut-être j'étais
très content quand je trouve ça mais
malheureusement là maintenant
malheureusement ça appartient pas que
ramon à notre laboratoire et quitte en
laboratoire c'est pas gagné
bon moi triche ou katia et les gars j'ai
bien ri c'est pourquoi la foudre pour
cette peur voilà pourquoi beaucoup plus
nous pour occuper au moins 3 mois mardi
et des deux enfin dire que toi tout seul
tu t'en vente des amis ce serait pas mal
de venir en tournoi et en fait tu es
derrière gris chucky tu le suis et il y
un mec bizarre me suit depuis des années
quoi qui comprend pas quoi ok à chaque
fois qu on a chaque fois il veut mettre
son goût sûr que si je parle doivent pas
à chaque fois elle veut donc absolue
mois on crie et l'opium désolé pour eux
mais je comprends pas c'est un peu dans
le style de garçonne qu'il nous faut
souvent mais je m'en doute ce qui m'a
vertu cette fois c'est une approche qui
est bien à chaque fois je pensais juste
non c'est juste ce doit être juste un
pur soupçonnant qu'à moi parce que c'est
pas pour ici mon ami parce que le pire
ne venait parfois c'est très intéressant
avec le noir bien sûr mais peut-être pas
comme les autres ados se retrouvent sur
à 7 tev a raison de faire des cinq tours
17 mai qui va te les n'oublions pas
aussi les échecs nous apprennent quelque
chose c'est d'être souple quant à ceux
qui ont les règles même les règles d'or
mais s'applique pas à chaque position à
chaque fois oui il faut être souple
quand même et ce que je vois dans le
judo parham silvio je vous aussi ce 5 il
le fait chaque fois besoin par
l'approché plus que critiquable
maintenant donc il va apprendre qu au le
fou sur eux sans quoi être très bon
parce qu'il va faire tout cela
maintenant elle ne te voit quoi dans le
sens d'être qu'il faut qu'ils fassent un
petit stage en russie pour travail vue
qui travaille beaucoup
s'il peut prendre ici peut-être france
ces points correspond toujours très bien
ici et paris quoi tu veux le faire un
petit stage
bah oui mais tu penses que si tu pedro
nous impose parfois parfois commente oui
il va chercher le poisson alors plus
inquiet papa côté mon valait d'ailleurs
libanais par contre tant mieux dans mais
je pense qu'à laurent qui est d'origine
libanaise dans le chat du juste comme ça
va ça n'a aucun rapport
non mais c'est étonnant de faire des
crises de l'ecfa ses gammes à ces anti
positionner non mais ce que j'aime pas à
chaque fois ceux qui ont à chaque fois
qu'ils les bonnes choses mais toujours
6e très critiquable grand temps que l'on
approche en fait
mais si vous me croyez pas me regarder
les parties de garçonne une fois à bord
il va faire c'est simple le taf avait
offert ses six les deux fois ils vont
même pas bougé depuis on sait mais
comment dire les échecs c'est pour
inventer un criez pas pour répéter ce
qui t'a donné du succès 3-1 au
championnat de la rue mais tout est mal
dans sa position son pion et mal son roi
ayman est ce qu'il ya à foule si c'est
fou comme je suis ok freudisme rien pour
l'instaurer peut-être d'ailleurs tout à
bien cette critique or elles ont tous
rêvent dans la tour ac semble aller dire
aux exactement ce que j'étais en train
de nos problèmes favori des livres
favoris ski mont rose tout je crois que
c'est pour le guerrier ski qui disait
commun ou spassky comment savoir quel
tour m sur la colonne choisi une émeute
l'autre d'ailleurs est ce qu'il ya un
moment donné un avantage
parmi le jour les murs joueurs de
l'époque
quel est votre favori dis moi quel a été
le co favori dos parce qu'ils pensent
parce que qu'elle est de son couvreur
free to a des seins qu'elle était le
coup favori donatien je dors quatre
forfaits rachetant 15 6 oui je veux dire
jusque là différence d approche et
carcelle c'est tout à b1 et h 2 h 4 et
tout le reste les deux en même temps
ouais et moi c'est g4 quel scoop qui me
qui est ce qu il fait l'un ok je dois
dire je vous ai avoué que tours avait
hâte que tout ça est un food court terme
de dos et un think you pour ne pas aller
d'une manière parfaite
là maintenant je pense que les blancs
n'ont plus grand-chose pour à nantes ne
peut pas faire cavaliers des cinq donc
fragile zahia fouiller cet épisode je
dois dire parce que normalement tu veux
pas échanger les foudres couleur et le
noir dans l'ailleurs cadres et les pions
de 5.5 parce que ça fait du cavalier 5
une pièce trop chic et écoute un peu
comme un temps après fou rire si ce taux
de 4 je dois dire je dois réputé qu'il -
murtha c'est la bonne époque fait pas
dur était fait parfois se joue ce que
les mecs heures parfois ils jouent bien
parfois elle est le monde certaines
joueurs durant l'hiver s'annonce pour
coiffeur à parce que bouquet atari oui
dans ce raid
les gens vont peut être prendre comme ça
comme ça mais dans ce cas là tout le
sens que je suis bien sûr tour de son
tour de sandra de retour ce 5 à perdre
sauf tour à tour et 6 donc tout ça sans
abri après et
et là maintenant et tu commences de
penser déjà et surtout bien autour aalto
racistes entonnés relais dames saisi les
biens non bien sûr je veux pas critiquer
très rare
sauf que il menace pas d'un locataire
tout ce 3 rue attend ici je cale tour d
un jeu menace m attendait 8
je voulais que le cas les tours à un
ouais il serait resté hyper fort très
très bien joué très très belle sans
aucun doute
moi qui ai tour fils ça gagnait ça
continue oui mais régis j'étais fier des
murs la main qui est ce que c'est que ça
ouh là où les gens là en fait nous
invoquer morato sud où avec les des
rockets tour soit un tour ces deux
pourquoi moque et pourquoi pas évoquer
bien sûr c'est bien aussi dû faire trois
tours j'ai six ou sept mois foot ou même
complètement futur hockey parfois ça le
joug devient bio enfantine le sport tu
sais quoi ils sortent ou réfutent b3
peut-être pour faire tomber dans ce mode
tout ce que tu vaux qu'escompté elle a
juste eu prend leïla elle-même avait
levé au tour hebdo balubakat rupture je
suis dans ce cadre c'est complètement
foutu tout de même après tours 2 par
exemple
ok tu peux même faire h5 leur
intermédiaire ok les mots tu m'as en
notant gosses se voit que tu n'y es mais
c'est pas la peine même si j'aime
victoire noire mais que ça se continue
alors jusqu'à la foire à tout le temps
où et pio les noirs ne sont pas que ok
mais les noirs juste grâce à toi tu te
rappelles qu'une avait joint une fois en
duo on avait fait le record sur ay si si
ça on dit aux gars séparément duo pas
moi c'était pas de suivre parce que
trois équipes vertes c'était ben oui
cette prime aux ouais mais mur passerait
pas grand chose et moi non plus ok to be
3 est bon mais pourquoi il fait perdre
de l'énergie il veut diminuer le nombre
des partis
un boulet ce serait à moi il faut sa
deuxième fois de la région avec une
pièce du moine et je voudrais donc
enfin
il n'est pas sûr qu est-ce qu on
blablate de base sur ce coup là j'ai la
dernière par non et je suis n'est pas
maintenant parce que je joue plus depuis
trois ans point ce parti - monica
revenir si j'y crois pas mais s'il y
aura plus des tournois chaos
je veux revenir avec un grand plaisir
mais malheureusement le feed
ils ont un peu commencé quand même la
super
vous savez notre maillot peut-être la
moitié aux responsables de la vie de
maintenant est composé des représentants
de la sip est donc maintenant à super et
la fille de cette motion est
malheureusement elles sont du mou
d'humour tellement conservateurs qui ont
bien sûr ils vont rien faire dans cette
direction là donc ça veut dire que je
veux pas revenir aux chèques
malheureusement parce que je sais très
bien qu est-ce que ce tour ski messieurs
il saute haut ce qu'ils pensent de tous
elle est donc malheureusement le monde
retourne pas dans le milieu
tiens d'ailleurs sur h35 de suite d'un
coup très intéressant
katchou h3b 5 je pense que c'est comme
ça que c'est continuer la partie qui a
entre 10 le courage 3 dans la pratique
de se montrer fischer match de revers
donc les deux plus gros spécialistes de
l'est
rien ici fischer a joué comme ça que je
pense et veut un match doit jouer au
foot je pense que maintenant ce mec-là
elle joue ici ce n'est pas soit joue
aussi soin et la questure catane
je sais plus mais cette partie brillante
avec gabin s'élèvent d'ailleurs c'est
une grosse quoi secteur la partie
fischer najjar si donc lomagne et la
manoeuvre comme l'aide de deux collèges
et trois qu'on vient de voir je pense
que c'était un produit par pour nos
malheurs mais pas avec les deux trois
mâts avec les décors les ce2 se trouvait
que les dégâts très intéressant c'est
pour nous marier très fin très fort
parce que 3 bien sûr c'est n'importe
quoi
excusez moi en français c'est n'importe
quoi quand blake comme les yeux crevés
liens se trouve sur deux est toujours
pas trois mais bon oh la la
peut-être qu'à maillage 5 donc il peut
arriver je ne sais pas le problème c'est
qu'ils vont te battre parce qu'ils sont
plus pratique avec favon à ce problème
pas assez fort en tactique pacé plus
faibles - juste nul partout fab pas
assez fort en tactique on voit parfois
j'ai l'impression que tactique
un calcul en dessous positionnelle pas
les fumeurs vertueux partout en afrique
on ne peut pas excuser
est ce que c'est vrai que je frime trop
en fait j'ai complètement oublié mon
talon d'achille mais sans grand talent
belge h il est chef
donc qu'est ce qu'il doit faire grève
quatre tours devra tout d'abord ok là
maintenant ou qu'ils aient trouvé la
façon de justifier comment commence
jusqu'à qu'on parle de ça comment on
passe d'un niveau
tu es très fort à une culture comme la
tienne en fait c'est que c'est quoi le
chemin pour y arriver en fait comment
faire ça non mais c'est juste que
jusqu'à l'âge de 18 ans que tu as les
filles m'ont pas intéresser du tout pas
du tout mon cas ils m'ont intéressé du
roi est plutôt tonique mans d'accord je
les ai contempler de ma fenêtre dérougit
pas d'autres de 5 200 m tu vois comme à
chaque fois là et donc tout ce qui
m'intéressait c'est les échecs mais
pourquoi il n'a pas fait dans des
systèmes les plus estimées dix mois dans
ce dossier ce que vous laissiez c'est le
cavalier sur ce cadre visent juste ou
donc tout ce que m'ont intéressé les
échecs donc six mois cool surtout
l'impression autant c'est parce que je
regarde d'autres choses parfois qu'est
ce que je vais essayer les livres et les
fenêtres
elle ne m'avait pas tu avais même pas
les films sur internet ou quoi à y
répondre et à l'union soviétique fait
même pas les journaux héros tikrit un an
il ya de quoi y en avait pas s'interdire
non la seule façon douce au mexique se
connecter à les positions érotique
c'était quand tu étais un voyageur de
l'etrat 1
il y avait livré vieux habits possible
d'être en train de vendre les cartes
érotique les cartes retirées car ferry
mais ils ont ils passé comme ça je sais
que de manière clandestine comme ça donc
et là tu pouvais te connecter à cette
industrie tellement
fascinante et utah fait déjà je vois
tout le monde tous ces mecs très louche
mais oui travaux se chiffre à qui et qui
voulait absolument qui tout à coup tout
de suite des concerts voici les noms oui
mais si et se fout il se faisait
rattraper par les flics le le père de ma
femme a raconté une histoire marrante
une anecdote par rapport à ça ils
étaient chez eux et regardaient la télé
tard par il a dit les flics sont montés
pour vérifier qui est pas le film dans
le cas cette saison à moscou ah non non
non c'est trop quoi ok tout intérêt
soudain pour elle ce n'est pas nos poids
mo pas d'amour pour elle ce n'est pas
qu'ils haïssent arrivé dans le port
comme dans mon époux qui sont venus
vérifier pourquoi vous regardez la télé
que les mecs louches de l'etrat c'est
quelqu'un sortir le temps des leurs a
dit oui c'est bizarre que c'est un peu
bizarre sa façon de gérer les élections
parce qu'ils ont tous réalisé du thouet
voyez ils menacent pas trop de trois
parce que 3 x 4 3 mais maintenant bien
sûr et les pas du tout mieux qui me
réussit parce que peut-être personnes
meurent ici parce que chacun a ses
atouts et les noirs ou un tour hyper
activement nous fout est mauvaise ici
les boîtes vont arriver avec mes paris
qu' il faut pas du tout cas où joue
l'adversaire quand même parce que si dos
santos à celle que les trois comme le
centre juste abandon et où commence à
qui il reste à l'autre de rentrer sur ce
site mais ils voient tous ses pieds son
coin mais qu'il manque 2 j'ai trop
juvénile
oui le grand format de jeu viennent tous
mais en fait c'est juste perdre
je pense qu'il est foutu on notera juste
après deux tours à 4 mais c'est
l'histoire juste des données pas même
essayé de cherchant peut-être d'attenté
le 5 puis on prend 1 pouces et 8 ou la
laisser sa chance neo qui aurait laissé
six inscrits masquer le fait que le cces
fourrage toi c'est pas l'amérique mais
tour à chanceaux bouche que le 7e volet
de ça que tu vois j'aimerais beaucoup
sur deux salles il je vis comme olivier
souhaite que jeffrey cole et ses 6 ans à
l'école parce que sur vos avis des colis
de 8 juste
d'ailleurs il n'ya rien de quoi
réfléchir il faut sacrifier ses pions
parce que nous fois le cavalier sur 2,5
et puis sur m6 c'est moi tu sois sûr
8,60 jouer tout ce qui arrive est assez
mature mais tu vois c'est ça la
différence c'est que toi tu vois vite
ces trucs là bas je ne vois pas je les
connais je vais le voir mais je me
rappelle juste mais c'est comment faire
pour réussir à les connaître tu vois
c'est ça le truc je te dis je te jure
convoqué mais si t'as plus 18 ans à il
faut quand même que les filles
s'intéressent pas à quoi ça c'est
important
ou bien il faut que les filles
s'intéressent pas à toi et l'union pour
toi fais de soutien pour voir ce que
c'est très facile et ça explique
pourquoi me repasser mes tiroirs par
exemple dans ta jeunesse 1
les belles filles les filles julie il
préférait quand même les mecs qu'on soit
costaud pas le genre de création de ma
jeunesse c'était concert sur les joueurs
de ce que non c'est pas ça non mais quel
moment elle va être mat sur ie8 ou
the whip selon le système que je viens
d'intégrer davantage si cela oui ma
cavale est de 5 cm pour chaque fois qu
il faut deux cavaliers ci sera je sais
tout autour de 300 cas pendant les
premières victoires blanc il ya deux
jeux à monsieur costaud aussi exemple ne
me dites pas propre à l'eau bout du
[Rires]
célèbre quand même à mach news oui c'est
vrai il sourit c'est vrai ma muse pas
naturellement
cependant pour l'exemple parce que c'est
pas en quoi c'est pas le terme ans j'ai
pas qu'elles commettent l'hermine chez
nous ben c'est dur mais il est très rare
au mac do caméra ah bah oui oui votre
bailleur à une phase toujours ses fautes
relations de rigueur je pense que c'est
digne de tu sais qu'il faut que tu
fasses à un match contre hikaru je pense
que oui oui je pense que ça peut être
très positif de m en répétition sur
vidéo histoire était très heureux
d'aller en usine par exemple tu te
réveilles tu vois ça c'est dommage qu'il
ait un pion h5 parce que sinon sur
cavalière six matches retours à vide
pour faire pousser 8 et surtout prend
faire la tour phone au roi aulas
d'ailleurs ça a été mon problème éternel
ce que toujours jamais trop bien pour
les patois à moment donné quelques
moyens ce mardi tony m'a complètement
gagné a complètement fermé à temps c'est
hyper infantile
ok ok mais dès septembre dans ce bizarre
quand même
e business e des collèges et les
revêtements je refuse à tout âge se
trouait fitou rage 5
ouais j'ai pensé à la même chose
j'aurais fait ça contre oui sauf que les
mecs mais s'il veut jouer même si même
après tout rien que vos joueurs à l'idée
c'est surtout reprend cas il prend la
finale et canadiens y fait d'ailleurs
pour ses biens au cas où elle devrait
sembler un cochon il continue quand même
non mais c'est pas respectueux un an
c'est bizarre non pour un russe
normalement ils abandonnent quand même
les vieilles légendes - les vieux bien
sûr y'a pas ce que tu continues à la
personne ni moto ni gris chaud clinique
à munich jusqu'à sont surtout parce que
ce coup là mais c'est quelque chose de
rsa quand même rage et 5
qu'est ce que tu vas faire en fait ok
dix mois les situations qui mène avec
ace quoi on regarde 4 buts 4 à 3
et c'est toujours le noir non c'est
toujours les grands arrêts blanc vient
de gagner la dernière a pour la première
fois
ok donc je vous ai dit déjà que vous
pouvez 5 x 5 x 6 x 6 2 6 4 sans problème
donc si vous n'êtes même pas ma façon de
comment tout au moins je vous ai donné à
la chine à fond et j'ai lâché l'info en
tant qu une compensation pour ma façon
de commenter trop ambitieux
l'ambitieuse trop frileuses à partir de
demain va s'amuser avec les parties
longues
à wu sérère de rigueur comme ça on
pourra philosophie zay pendant 45
minutes sur une pause à raconter des
trucs sur les anciennes
ouais c'est plus facile de commenter
bien ça mais je pense que enfin on en a
parlé mille fois qu'ils ont le mieux le
meilleur cadre pour
comment tu es bien sûr ce rapide d'un
côté comme de l'autre côté assez
dynamique
mais c'est la meilleure qu'à danser sur
des airs cette fois ci c'est sarah na
qui a le plus isolé - sauf que je ne
pense pas que le réussi quoique ce soit
ainsi que voulez vous c'est d'ailleurs
je sais même pas de quoi l'autorité
comme les baissiers ces jeux tellement
analyser des positions avec le pion
désolée surtout ce dernier table en fait
toute ma vie surtout de les derniers
trois semaines est-ce que vous dire que
comme le précise plan des gouverneurs
les blancs n'ont rien du tout - ou avoir
des problèmes
c'est sûr quand on a commencé la ligne
médiane h soirée dansante
comme ce sens qu'est ce que ces fins les
dents se sentent bien sûr et comment tu
vois ces trucs là aussi parce que c'est
le premier instant ça s'était très bien
vrai déjà forcé faucheux 3g c'est une
bonne idée pour les blancs parce que le
bios trois voix défendant la casaque 4
ça c'est une fenêtre pour l'euro à
préparer sinon éventuellement à jour
plutôt que 14,5 moyen que de bons côtés
quoi non mais c'est hyper bien vrai
c'est fou de voir aussi à des bons
instants corps mais peut-être le jonc
que d'être élevée bouffer sur ce site
100 jours pour un vieira double attaque
tu as les gens demandent suite rappelle
la scène mythique de basic insight
est-ce que je me rappelle double 6-1 6-1
hébergeur tu la regardes et pas qu'une
fois ce qu'il j'ai peut-être heures
consacrées au sacré toujours à lui de
quoi peut-être ne doit plus qu à
l'estudiantes quoi avec une
microscopique sur les craintes
c'était sûr que la question de pleurer
[Rires]
donc il va faire rage suite je pense
mais il réfléchira y fit tu pousses
braille fiscal un peu nouveau pour moi
qui mets fois h4 non mais qu'est ce que
c'est que ça aurait fait je ne pense pas
que symbole instant que je ne pense pas
et je vois aucune raison pour le faire
mais bon sang le jour je sais sont très
durs à comprendre parce que lors comment
dire leur paternel qui ne sont pas
encore aussi conservative que les miens
ok l'auteur bayonne il montre une
approche intéressante elle doit faire
n'importe quoi quand les jets cessna et
si vous réussissez le voir il veut faire
peut-être faut bouger faut acheter du
fourrage et la direccte et à quoi les
recettes non je parlais de foot à
montoir bons d'autres moins
ok matin surtout réussi c'est
l'équivalent de 6 h est donc peut-être
le temps est arrivé pour jouer ou
rejouer c'est un blanc sur noir
hayots achkhar de retour de six ok donc
sous je veux pas critiquer attends tu
vas faire d'en prendre cavale et j'ai si
souvent et si ce qu'est ce que tu
réussis j'ai cassé sa structure ici une
finale plus ou moins légale parce que tu
as la case où sera oui pour égaliser
c'est pas mal pour égaliser sport
algérien ne pense pas que
oui parce que dame de quoi comme olivia
wilde en tâtant cavaliers g6 tu prends
oui je prends la route tue frange ramène
une tour web cet âge est pas sorti ok je
me rentre dans la même finale gérard
fouet cette fois pas là des fossés avec
celle avec qui je peux pas tourner ça
dans un autre sens d'autres manières il
ne peut pas obtenir plus que ça avec les
banques parce que sinon il n'a pas trop
bien joué ces derniers couler sinon il
va souffrir et mesdames et froid c'est
peut-être tout maintenant
roy j'ai vite maintenant il faut
souffrir pour être prêt maintenant à
leur coin d'où aussi s'il veut faire
quoi pour 4 kg système doit naître de
revivre ça c'était ok je plus rien à
dire je capte pas grand chose parce que
c'était horrible comme les décisions il
l'a même pas vu autour de 7,6 ouais ok
là maintenant elle va faire je sens qu
il montre que la pâte complexe mais en
fait aux échecs mes amis vaut mieux de
voir des complexes celle inverse de la
vie vaut mieux de faire complexer dans
la vie aussi par là mais pas je passe le
bon à 504 km
quoique requis en septembre est ok dans
le cadre d'un g4 de russie ce qui
peut-être les positions de pas sorti de
l'égalité encore durer six mois gérer
quand même jeff bewkes bouaké le piano
géant orange en faisant ce cas car mon
bus juste pour bloquer parce que tu as
peur pas justement
mais c'est bien de décrocher un peuple
autre nom
[Rires]
est ce qu'on va voir réussissent dans
cette partie et le sacrifice
positionnelle du bio qu'est-ce qu'on
avait un 4 pour qu'il cède 17 et rick
apprendre quelques idées de toute
évidence par un bateau de crier les uns
kbit s il fait un peu trop quand même
parce que les fourchettes 1 4 qui est
des quatre d'un bep quatre tours 2-2
c'était pas si clair la tour au nom d un
après
donc bon je sais pas comment juger ça je
pense que cette dernière pendant ce
dernier coup là je préfère quand même
les noirs jodoigne attends je suis pas
faire f 4 non tu peux pas dur des quatre
dames en fait fallu faire être 4 direct
ici que les d4 d'âneries quatre voies g7
non c'est trop en fait plus sens c'est
moi qui vois paquet au noir pour toi qui
crèvent quelqu'un mais les droits sont
mieux c'est clair et net les deux
semaines après n'importe qui comme
peut-être au kg 4 pas parce que et 5,2
me 5,4 et le tour du qatar conjugue 10
12 et 4 quittance de gadsen seul coup
non y'a quoi y'a peu de terreau gt4
gratuit pour les blancs noirs
c'est très dangereux parce que c'est
très facile de se faire remarquer qu'au
préfet f5 la porte du top 14 il ya eu
autour des 4 c'est quand même déjà vu un
truc surtout c4 après non mais ils
avaient sûrement pas vu surtout
secrétariat vous asseoir dans le 3me
souriante
la menace est donc là je pense qu'obama
a toutes les chances d'augmenter son
avantage jusqu'à 5 3 ce qui va se
produire bien sûr je n'ai aucun doute
parce qu attends attends c'est pas fini
kimoce dédain jeudi strike
non mais là vous connaît pour l'instant
stribe au genou koné bruno je dois dans
le droit non surtout tu veux surtout les
bords bull 6e réussit non mais là tu
veux toucher 3 maintenant sur dame ça me
6c il sait pas quand harry caine je
pensais ok mais tu as me 3 quand même
et je veux dame g5 l'étranger 4 oui tu
as raison
çà çà çà çà compliqué ça c'est beaucoup
compliqué bien c'est ce qui vous vient
ce président j'en vois des trucs quand
même où est donc il faut admettre que le
plus probablement il est perdu tout son
avantage
les honnêtes des blancs sont mis à mal
il écrire une chose qu'ils ont il est
devenu plus facile de jouer et qu'il
doit ce qu'on aimerait passer plutôt les
bois qui vise le roi
avant c'était le noir il ya encore
quelqu'un mais regarde plus je vais
peut-être mais je ne pense pas que les
positions de sortie de l'égalité je
pense pas je ne serais pas fait mais à
un moment donné il faudra absolument je
réussis je sais pas quel moment
peut-être maintenant un miroir josé
jover les pirelli jouer ou pas du tout
ok ça jusqu'en couffignal et les montres
et déjà éculées la tendance était mieux
fini il est la nôtre et que tu laisses
et damages cinq ans - qu'est-ce qui est
sûr dans 24 tours 4 hay adams histoire
d'âme si c'est normal il faut brûler
leur foi nous libérer mais qui régit
combat quand je fais 2 6 d'agréage mort
a réfléchi gens normalement tu as a
calculé ça
il va bien mais quand même ouais mais
roche 2 c'était ok d'argent 6 voiles
amateurs sur quatre bon ok il apporte
menace comment les sociétés all seasons
paris à elle veut tout réussi s'excuse
le réaliser quand même non c'est pas si
clair rien normalement vois je sais pas
où tu veux faire
même si tu peux pas bien joué mais les
hypers et flatté et c'est tout oui donc
tout retour j'ai trois pour bien sûr tôt
j'ai eu trois pattes au e3 alors attends
c'est chaud tour d'essai tu as
m'attendre bah ouais parce que l'autre
tout faux bond
keller veut pas bien sûr le volet hockey
qui menacent encore courage c'était
cavaillon et cavaliers et ou rachètent
camaïeu de fini non il va pas abandonner
ok il pleurait je sais pas comment un
décalage avec la pendule il reste une
partie
il aurait pu jouer un peu pour tu vois
en fait il
bizarre ce qui fait mais je pense que
par am après un gros avantage en
ascendant psychologique
ok donc h3 est ce que l'autre va répéter
avec besoin ou pas non il faut et locaux
beaucoup plus populaire que ressentent
donc 5 ou qui est ce qu a dit iouri ci
est énormément de tueur il faut se
serrer encore un lieu plus populaire ce
que voulaient descendre ses chers
joueurs quant à l'inde joue comme ça les
autres je pense à ça c'est con quoi
pas tout à fait principal je pense que
ici qu'est ce que je fais moi j'ai avec
le noir la mort sans que un peu trop
bizarre à mon goût mais c'est pas le
spécialiste du secret
moi je n'ai jamais donné ça que j'ai
même pas eu cette idée de jeu de
massacre ici parce que normalement la
dame appartient pas à saint-just jeu
s'oppose au faubourg maintenant et après
le cavalier peut-être voir des f 5
pouces
on ne nous pas du tirage au sort de
demain tu sais comment ça se passe ce
tirage au sort des grands prix je pense
que le tirage au sort et pendant les
cérémonies de bureau et les cérémonies
d'ouverture va être le seul soir
ce soir on aura d'homme peu de temps
parce qu'en fait les gens pensent que
ces têtes de série numéro 1 contre tête
de série numéro 16 mais c'est pas le cas
là quelqu'un écrit que cette double un
nom en fait ils se trompent s'ils
pensent que ces numéros en compte numéro
16 mais ce n'est pas le cas il ya un
tirage au sort ils se trompent voit que
pointue de la carrière d'arthur super
fort bon ça a été une grosse carrière il
a beaucoup réussi puis tant qu il a vu
qu'il peut plus jeune homme me roule
s'est mis à écrire les livrets
entraîniez le jour donc j'ai qui aura
plein de trucs ces livres sont
excellents d'ailleurs je sais ok je suis
pas un grand fan à parce que pour moi
c'est excusez moi pour moi c'est c'est
pas énorme ce livre parce que c'est pas
censé être écrit pour moi oui mais je
suppose que pédagogiquement parlant pour
ceux qui sont moins forts c'est
excellent et je suppose que se doit ce
doit être excellent quoi pour moi
personnellement même si renault c'est un
grand monsieur j'ai croisé d'autres
manières écoutez je préfère voir
quelqu'un comme lui en train d'écrire le
livre surtout de bons livres qui au dos
continuer de jouer et jouer moi en bien
sûr c'est toujours ça m'a toujours crève
le coeur de voir quelqu'un qui était
troisième au monde qui joue maintenant
j'ai pas moi que de récents je pense que
vous voyez de qui je parle
niamey quinté numéro 1 qui sont 2006
aussi je passe et c'est pour moi à
chaque fois ça me crève le coeur c'est
triste oui bien sûr ce prix je préfère
un la façon de kasparov de partir et la
façon de fisher de partir la façon de
chroniques de partir par rapport à la
fois sont deux autres maintenant de même
il résiste bien en or pour l'instant
c'est encore dans la normalité
- il est parle d'eau
dorrans traite de la situation mouche
déjà les palois je pense qu'il est pas
loin de du moment quand il faudra partir
je pense légal font pareil les cobayes à
écouter les cours il joue presque plus
il est très sûr tout n'est donc qu'à
pauvres ne veut pas sa façon de partir
non pas du tout je pense que trop
souvent au cours de ces dernières dix
années il se fait ridiculiser et c'est
plutôt dommage parce que c'était ses
liens tels les gens et pour l'un des
plus grands joueurs champions du monde
tout le temps est court souvent de se
faire ridiculiser ceux d'origine
lorsqu'ils se déplacent pour jouer les
greuze
il faut être deux parties avec les bois
il faut il dire ce petit nuls en quinze
coups et à écouter monsieur car pauvre
quand même donc non je passais je passe
à et par rapport à ce que c'est pas sur
l'échiquier motta je pense que c'est
équilibré où je pense que c'est plus
facile de jouer avec les doigts il
faudrait pour le suspense que sarah n'a
réagi monfils
qu'est ce que vous voulez amorphis et là
des programmes je n'y ai tout le temps
génie je souligne le monde j'ai nié
parce que je n'aime pas utiliser le mot
génie souvent leur fiche que se dire en
tant que tel appareil qui au fil des
fils de notre compatriote
ils voient le jour que je pense vaut
mieux qu aux dames où que ce soit mais
vaut mieux qu part parce que il est pas
loin de se faire ridiculiser
non c'est triste des gens comme ça il
faut savoir arrêter on manque
c'est comme avec les filles recevoir le
bon moment de partir et ce pas aussi
venir et partir partir aussi et revenir
[Rires]
donc j'aurais bien aimé cette décision
de serrana de donner le coeur parce que
c'était trop dur de jouer ça maintenant
ça va tout témoin si objectivement les
boissons mieux bien sûr ça va devenir
plus facile de jouer parce que plus d
espace quoique bien sûr le problème
c'est le roi aurait mais il n'est pas
m'as tu encore même si un jour je si ce
n'est pas ma encore dans le sens du
rythme enfin si les blues n'ont pas le
temps pour h4 et h5
c est dans la normalité jamais fait un
four 4 ans oui d'accord mais est ce que
ça va donner quelque chose donc je vois
pour jussiê se trouve 8h30 les questions
ch qataris que les bons auront le temps
pour dames de 5,084 moi je sais pas
comment ils étaient cadenassés peintre
jeudi s'il veut mettre son cavalier sur
ce dossier se poindre juridique du tout
parce que souvent le cavalière n'est pas
aussi bien pour célébrer ce n'est qu'une
illusion d'optique
souvent nous devrions même moi ça m'est
restée en travers juste pour trois tours
chez 3
j'aurais pas 1000 camions saisis parce
que c'est faux je pense qu'il est le
joue moins juste la meute à ascot
ouille ça par contre oui donc la madame
deux sets vite faut être deux ans domine
tout de suite et voici qu'est ce que tu
veux oui la zsl est question cette fois
je crois à la tour est en prison ça va
sauf que qui est la tour bouge kelkoo tu
fais moi je vais faire à georges
marchais quatre tours et un prix de
cardio 7 mai 7 passes si vous montrer
totalement je sais c'est qu'à faire vos
biotteau au sud de recettes comme si
vous y étiez
mode opérationnel que les revendraient
ce cadre en étant que dans 17 bien sûr
avec l'été bouffer tout ok non mais ces
dernières couleurs savoir qu on était
quatre connaissez si bien sûr c'était
moi je le signe de joux vienne alité au
commanditaire tous les poneys jeux
vénalité je verrai ça n'existe pas
comment je comprends comme un dixième de
moins que je vienne habiter la terre
comme vous il y en a ce qui est parfois
écrits de les commentaires pour nos
visuels que je suis dire pour les
néologismes c'est pas 2 pour durer
jusque vous cru ce que n'est pas le mot
le mot jeu en blocs du tiff où la rote
olalalala la démo créatif très bien bien
mais ça va pas se produire parce que
leurs élèves topologie tout le monde a
vu ça c'est ça le problème donc et il va
jouer quoi attendre cette fois je crois
ça problème non ça ça ça serait bien ça
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait ici à la
temp on l'a vu ils ont tous vu mais
france 3
le problème c'est que you il menace rien
il veut rien s'il faut 4 après ça au
théâtre est tout aussi tranquille et
heureux la dame coup d'ailleurs
cavaliers si ça prouve d'ailleurs je
n'ai critiqué pour cette décision mais
en fait
[ __ ] l'a très bien pris le cavaliere 7
il faut 9 4 quand je peux vous faire
adresse que tu peux vraiment me faire si
le matériel
dans ce sens quintin finir comme si
souvent dans ce match qui était cavalier
set quand même faut quatre turcs cavale
et 1,7
est-ce que je anneaux faut aussi je n'ai
pas que vous êtes peut-être je fous h
6/4 et 10-8 a nommé coo tessin n'a pas
juste bien sûr ça dérange moins à jouer
ça c'est beau non
oui c'est beau et fort ok tour de huit
obligatoire dans de la magie quatre
peut-être ça fait mal ça fait mal ok là
donc peut-être à wihr qui viennent à se
tromper dans nos maisons nos analyses
d'avant peut-être non parce que si ça
s'est bien passé dans les parties se
vêtir pas qu on n'avait pas raison vient
faire dans ma chair mais le cavalier si
ça promet d'être bien placé est ce que
vous leur se souvient de ce qu'il lui
avait dit à propos de qui viennent
travail pour compliquer son ensemble
qu'est ce que je dis il m'a mis en place
il a dit que j'étais très intelligent
parce que j'avais aucun talent pour les
échecs ce que tu avais aucun cas
l'apologie scrabble face à nom très
marrant cet euro ah c'était quand il
faisait les soirées
si vous avez rencontré ira d'ailleurs si
vous avez rencontré ira on se rappelle
ses soirées il avait dit ça j'étais
foutu de ma gueule pendant un certain
moment vous là de parler de ce que je
découvre qu'entre joueurs qui devraient
prendre leur retraite en fait pour moi
ça a toujours été un gir d'ailleurs j'ai
pas j'aime par les sujets qu en fait
jamais j'ai parlé de ça les unes se voir
mais doué homme auquel résistance
rejouer de monsieur soit f8 d'un des six
il y avait 13 4 a trop fait d'en prendre
ok maintenant tout ce que tu veux bien
sûr quéméré this can
mais tu connais cette expression chez
les ressources king's day bien sûr les
russes n'abandonne pas se pâmer -qui le
procureur broker
tiens tiens
mais il se défend pas mal quand même non
oui c'est bon il ya tout qui est cloué
mais le problème ici c'est que l'absence
totale des défauts de il faut h5 donc
excusez moi mais savoir faire déjà 6 3
ça fait mal ça fait mal et les situation
devient critique donc la connaissance du
style de serrana donc émerger les
mairies anneaux va peut-être se trompent
tu sais en france on a une petite
expression quand la situation est
dramatique
la tees la dédramatise voilà bon il est
temps de mettre une pub on revient dans
cinq minutes
sa coupe comme ça à tout ne partez pas
stay tuned
[Musique]
bon l'élite on est de retour sur une des
questions à vlad n'hésitez pas à nous
brouiller pas d'ailleurs que demain
demain demain demain à partir de 14h on
sera en direct pour suivre
nv elle avec la ddt et ouais ce sera
important de partager tout ça mais on
vous en parlera demain parce que parce
que c'est quand même assez exceptionnel
de pouvoir profiter de des analyses de
vlad comme ça je crois
j'espère en tout cas et donc on suivra
on suivra le 3 le grand prix fidh avec
vlad les parties de maxime en
intégralité à partir de demain et on a
on a vraiment de la chance de l'avoir
parce que c'est le joueur français
capables de commenter qui a eu la plus
belle carrière en imaginant que maxime
puisse pas commenter
et donc j'ai juste relancer un petit peu
en avance histoire de voir si c'était
s'était paré bla de revient et c'est
vrai qu'on est nombreux ce soir donc
n'hésitez pas à mettre le petit follow
sur la chaîne comme ça vous pourrez voir
nos commentaires à partir de demain où
on suivra le numéro un français maxime
vachier lagrave qui tentera de se
qualifier pour remporter le titre de
champion du monde
mais donc ce match c'est sympa
malheureusement peut-être manque un peu
de suspense
donc là ça va reprendre bientôt recèlent
les mecs
écoutez legacy qui cadeaux parmi vous
apprendre les appareils radio mada et
enfin pouvoir nous écrire et comme ça on
pouvait on pourra fils suffisait sur les
appareils mois kizuki qu'il est là
comment dire on l'a dit daniel et le
rapport des styles qu'il est le rapport
de la force
as quel est le rapport de verture et où
moi ça m'intéresse énormément
on nous demande c'est à dire je le temps
à des candidats est ce que voient déjà
jouer les tournois critiques de nos
enfants j'ai avant une fois j'ai passé
assez loin dans les tournois ko dès le
tournoi chaos dans la contenance qui
donnait titre de champion du monde à
l'époque où est maintenant ça s'appelle
coupe du monde à l'époque c'était le
championnat du monde comme j'ai passé
jusqu'au quart de finale où j'ai perdu
au compteur monde élèves représentent
donc j'ai perdu contre ils jouent donc
vous savez vous voyez donc mais parfois
les métiers dits bio de blizzard mort et
commence bizarrement parfois on a été
beaucoup plus jeune que toi parce que tu
sais en fait j'ai les meilleures
relations avec ceux qui m'ont coûté le
plus riche au quai wilson financièrement
parlant parce que plusieurs fois quand
il s'agissait du gros poignant j'ai
perdu contre l'un de l'autre
un congrès tout a perdu souvent pour le
gros pognon avait perdu à canon a quant
à elle perdu congard non mais à l'époque
je t'ai pas moins fort que oui non pas
du tout à l'époque mais il a montré que
ceux là ont été nettement mieux que
lumière naturelle et pondère même
maintenant malheureusement il ya des
questions mène maintenant
malheureusement avec delage
malheureusement il n'est plus du tout
laurie choquant bougera bol de riz
zschokke qui peut offert douze coups aux
premières lignes de filières lorsqu'il a
30 secondes mais ça c'est impressionnant
malheureusement ce plus en plus souvent
le cas en fait moi mais comment il
faisait salaires ben justement parce que
les phrases en quoi il est trop jeune
elle est gelée au niveau du système
nerveux
il était maintenant il est plus mais
maintenant malheureusement avec chaque
bourse peut-être il devient plus
il devient de plus en plus comment tu es
sûr de ça il y en a des gens qui se
déshumanise avec chaque cause de plus ce
qui est humaniste qui est élu meilleur
joueur de celle de tout le temps vlad
apparu mains écoutaient je pense
est-ce que magnus magoni je pense que je
parle pas de mac nous parce que l'être
trop tôt d'en parler
d'accord on pourra jauger lorsque sa
carrière c'est fini je suppose mais moi
je cassais dire j'ai toujours dit ça je
considère qu'il y avait trois génies de
l'histoire des échecs c'est fils dorment
aussi fait cher les autres je considère
pas entendu en tant qu au génie et à
chaque fois que les gens écrivent que
kasparov était un génie ça m'énerve
parce que les génies avec 25 secondes en
je les considère pas comme légers mais
tu vas pas de faire un ami avec fab
c'est son genre préféré mon amour
joueurs préférés sur une autre chose je
parle du mot génie parce que le mot
génie jinho sapho motreff warwick davis
états unis je pas
[Musique]
pour le cocan peut-être mon oui d'accord
par le ghana pour lequel je suis pas sûr
d'habitude tout le monde le sait quoi
donc gêné c'est un prêt fois
bon peut-être pas capable en car je me
demande dans le chatt pas assez
travaillé bachot pense qu il justement
il a passé outre il n'a pas eu assez du
travail après le talent nord mais aussi
leur travail et autant sur les kin
il aurait pu être nommés comme juni mais
je pense que bridge où les les fans de
la belle époque l'intéressait toujours
plus qu'une souche est donc en fait sur
les femmes le problème
ok maintenant fawcett food et si cet
impôt faut cette photo c'est ce qu'est
ce que c'est que ce soit au moins deux
ans au delà
mais qui est le manque de culture où
elle alla à gand mais attends tu en sais
pas ce qu'il veut empêcher le 4 et le
jeune kevin systèmes c4i parce que le
29.4 un rebond qui est les fouilles 6 me
faut c'est bien sûr fawcett faut des six
que vos livres 6 c'est comme ça qu'il
rentrait de telles positions en
permettant de 5 c
c'est original c'est criminel est en
fait en témoigne une partie de deux
criminels
deux jeunes voyous coin et y compris lé
guen l'oscar scarla ce carreleur ok
maintenant je pense que les positions de
plus ou moins égales chacun dans ses
atours
ok mais les noirs doivent faire gaffe
quand même et donnait pas recette de
changer l'eau foot couleur noire parce
que si les bornes arrive et changer le
fou et mettre le cabinet sur 5 ça va
être un problème
donc il faudra il faudra savoir le
parier et bien sûr nos rangs c'est une
bonne idée d'essayer de mettre le fou
sur 6 et de 5,8 puisque cavalière de 5
c'est pas sûr que c'est résolu le
problème qui peut sauf que petit à sion
à 3 élus rejouer à centrer peut-être ça
reste des délais vers militaire à 3,5
bouffe je peux être à tour bouffe
cavalière 5
je vois une telle cité probable
comme ça qu'avec les défauts ce que vaut
le sens qu ici rouages où il faut 7 6 5
ça ça ça collait au collet c'est juste
ça peut arriver maintenant donc ok
comment gérer traiter cette position là
où je suis bien fière je veux pas
critiquer ça je suis cool est-ce que je
peux offrir acheter un nom d'amal vrai
google france il faut compter six objets
d'art j-6 faut juste que voler h5 dans
cette histoire d'âme à fait d'accord
dans le filtre à 08 quand les jets cette
excuse moi qu'est-ce que je sers veut
donc se jouer le jeu c'est possible
l'africa et 5 qui joue mieux
non mais t'es mauvais on va mettre leur
vie mais je pense pas pourquoi moi j'ai
fait un tempo mais c'est juste instant
mais alors il nous reste à jouer sur la
justice bon bon bon peu tu as été bon
dans tous les cas car les cinq jeunes
part parce que le problème des doigts si
lecavalier aurait été sur deux les bois
doubs convenu que trois c'est une grosse
compensation ouais mais là le problème
c'est qu'il est très mal placé à
l'isolément
c'est un genre de van gogh peut-être
fausse trop alors maintenant force 3
avec le décor le club attend il n'y a
rien dont il veut dire que ce soit
intéressant non intéressés intéressant
rien à dire intéressant
ouais c'est intéressant non mais tu es
si je sors g5 et h5 peut-être ok d'un
grossiste dans le cadre quoi qu'il faut
214 heures c'est désagréable de laisser
ça non que vaut les âges sans que si
kovalev 6-2 2-1 mais carey la chaîne
sanitaire grave qu'est ce que c'est que
ça pourquoi elle nous fait ça il est de
son adversaire qui vient d'égaliser
maintenant car bien sûr de 4 des cadeaux
abed hamoud 6,6 colère cinq dames au
sens oui c'est étonnant non oui il nous
faut - il faut moins de ta proposition
n'a été mille fois mieux qua non mais
c'est étonnant ils échangent des dames
ok ça reste bien pour les blancs le pour
les noirs pardon mais c'est pas une
grand chose non
mais on sait bien parler moi on en
retour ces huit tours ces dates
auxquelles les noirs peuvent pas être
moins bien mais peut-être peut-être les
noirs ne sont pas la mienne en prenant
ce qui n'arrive pas à rentrer maintenant
plus de trois jeux cette commerçante
pour réfuter alors moi parce que dans
ces cas là la case de 20h
ok mais tour des torts et c'est pour ça
tu peux faire annuler quoi - jour je
vais vite là parce que tours de 6 h 5
quand le 5 turbo c'est pas idiot mais
bond de 7 ha oui il est clair que c'est
comme ça tout réussi cet ouvrage 56 sa
seconde sur une turbine gaz a été réussi
avec as voyages 5 à + tour de et à tour
ici à a brillament ils font à 8 des
bambins sète - tours beauce est
peut-être derrière autour bouaziz caf il
a fini par remettre le faut enlever
cette façon ok d'autres moyens là il est
ça n'a pas aller à madrid peut être tour
à deux vitesses une faute mais il a
maltraité saleh les ailes et le futur
traitant mieux pour le suspense
ouais bien sûr
billy smith creek dans le chatt possible
pas sûr donc la période perdue
ok donc plus d'eau pour parham aux tiens
il n'a pas joué au jeu h3 cette fois-ci
faut deux photos mais pas que les 200
créé l'émoi h4 s'étaient introduits par
sow c'est moi il ya quelques mois
c'était un plaisir perso je sais pas je
n'ai pas analysé donc je vais pas vous
mentir je connais pas grand chose tapez
analyser ce que great yuzhou parana au
prince ces derniers temps là ils le
jouent pas trop rires et je sais pas
mais ça passait à côté de moi donc je
vais parler et ça je pense pas que les
réactions de noir et très convaincant
par contre je pense pas parce que
normalement quand tu as roulé les pions
comme ça rien qu à cause de l' avantage
un espace libre en plus on respire et
des terminaux de jeunes parce que quand
même réussi trop ici je pense je refais
faucheux 400 réfléchir parce que fout de
4 dans ce cadre j'adore la dame sur
quatre non elle est bien placée
sinon je suis sa chanson qu'il faut 4 3
il n'y a pas de payer rien donc je 4g
sinon mais je crois pas ces chemins
ces matchs dont je crois pas il faut
être cinglé f4 je pense que c'est rouge
oui c'est trop moche non encore là
maintenant les décisions désagréables à
faire bouffer sur giguère aulas attend
h5
qu'est ce que c'est que ça foca
territoire fuji 5,65 à feu que vous les
six victoires bon j'en attends à chaque
attaque
hagège entourage 7 et d'un an dans le
temps en temps ça forge toi f4 faut
bouger au bâton
ça s'est fini non ok ce jour sont faux
at il oui en fait il y il est pas stable
le mec non c'est bizarre il n'est pas
stable
elle est vraiment pas stable il est le
plus aux jouets près four mais parfois
tu te dis moi même quartier la jalousie
site a même envie que même s'il faut
prendre du pain de quelques franges et
ça a été un objet ci-après d'enjeux 3 il
n'y a pas de nappes de chance pour
petites bêtes
ok tu doit calculer juste et le prix sur
12 semaines donc je trouve à erévan
jouer dans mon frère parce que les mots
de madame lagarde
il va être forcé à faire cette barge
dont il va faire froid au dos comme il
voit le fait d'un jeu de voix quoi comme
jeu st croix de trois par jeu 3 c'est
pas pire était présent non mais il a
fait n'importe où dans le jeu 2 ou la
banane on attend war iii de la droite 3
dames g53 f2 au contraire très bien joué
dans le cadre d'un f3 il donne rien là
il laisse pas un millimètre très bien
joué dans ça c'était bien bon ça s'était
très bien fait c'était bien cette
chouette ça c'était bien
on en rencontre vous parlez de contester
ou de nous avec kim mais attends c'est
bien joué d'orage en hockey on en mange
est roi où deux ou plus on prend non
mais je suis content de cette partie de
parme parce que c'était beau roi des 2/3
machin c'était très instructif
le triangle le fameux triangle que ça tu
peux donner comme exercice à hâter mec
quoi tu trouves pas kyocera may a une
gueule d'hommes moynier accès réel je
vois ce que tu veux dire mais non tu
vois pas je vois qui pourrait faire
penser mais moi je pense qu'il est nul
avec les tendances maniaque l agence et
je les amenais a vu un vrai oui ici
non je pense pas
en fait pourquoi il continue à jouer
ouais pureté resserrement pense que
bullet il est foutu
de toute manière et l'amérique et
visqueux il cherche de minimiser les
dégâts
je pense qu'il est très émotif et qui
crache cuisse contout les maniaques
cyrielle oriane la hollande à la tâche
moi je veux cette petite variante avec
eux quatre ces six c'est pas le mieux de
sens que c'est plus intéressant parce
que parfois c'est intéressant de garder
la case c6 libre et pour maintenir le
cavalier regarder les parties de
christian bauer
il nous fait très bien ça ceci est tout
de suite c'est finir n'est pas trop
précis à fait ok mais tu as qu'il va
faire juste peut-être ce même jour
pendant mon vol et de cette audition
comme le sacré peut-être pas maintenant
non je pense que le bois ou réussis de
voir une bonne version de la tâche en
fait parce que carl libourne réussissent
à passer leurs cavaliers de cette
manière là avec votre survie 3,5 et bon
toujours un avantage dans cette version
normalement les noirs essaie d'éviter ça
à tout prix mais j'aime pas je savais
que les blancs et avec les noirs ou les
bois juste un bon avantage aussi en fait
il n'y a pas de contre jour là
maintenant le reste de la partie va être
triste pour le noir parce que ça va être
la torture à quoi le cabinet va se
déplacer sur 100 je parle de comment les
toits puis après r3 qu'elle ait des six
se sent que le bouche brigade b5 tu vois
ce que je veux dire n ont pas de côté
joueurs c'est ça l'avenir de noir comme
les cavaliers sont placés de 7
manière harmonieuse à réduire nos futurs
pas ouais
no future vous vous rappelez du sous le
regard des banques dans les années 70
jean cys rappelle nos futurs je pense
qu'ils connaissent tu pense qu'ils sont
trop jeunes dans le chatt possible de
franchir
je pense que tes commentaires sont
surtout suivie par les autres n'ont fait
bon non plus grosse tranche ces genres
23 35
donc mon futur donc maintenant donc les
questions ce devoir et qu'il n'est qu'il
est les tigres changera l'image a fait
dix ans qu'il a une bonne technique ok
ils menacent de pouffer sur ces quatre
pour avoir la force de deux heures - m6
ou décès à voir l'ébauché source de donc
les vieux jeux de fdn sans réfléchir
dans cette position les gens pensent à
ce 5 mai les vieux essaie de garder la
souplesse de robson qui s'élève
direction plus ou moins maintenant dans
de telles positions verser 1,1 à tous
les jours sans réfléchir besoin notre
alphabet 500 réfléchir pour moi d'avoir
la cascade à l'inversé et d'ailleurs je
pense que c'est un bon réflexe parce que
parfois quand tu joues en prise contre
lui de telles positions parfois ils te
prouve que vous il faut éviter mieux que
je peux non mais c'est un truc
paradoxale quand un fou qui est
tellement mauvais il est plus si mauvais
que ça mais faut bien mourir ce qu'on
t'a leur donne à hollywood c'est il
existe des films cultes qui sont
tellement mauvais un qu'elles sont
devenues cultes sont appelle ça les
nanars en français h comme ce parlement
c'est par exemple les sharks asharq
le film de paul verhoeven le strip tease
gauche c'est par rapport aux filles de
las vegas strip tease bio seau d'eau
chaude aux joggers c il est toujours
donnée comme le milieu exemple que
soubrette de good way marc nadeau très
connu aussi c'est que tu connais lequel
sharks nadeau on pourra regarder suivant
soir
ok j'ai pas encore vu mais il paraît
qu'il est très nul mais tu te rappelles
quand j'étais à mais j'adore le film
orgueil mais tu sais qu'on regarde je
considère poids contenu du tout je te
rappelle parfois ont regardé les films à
3 heures du matin sur pierre v canal où
la première chaîne très bons films
souvent quoi qu'est-ce que c'était
débile je pense qu'il a tout gâché
c'est râlant ce qu'il fait je pense que
cela apporte quoi parce que je vois pas
comment une fois percé sur le dos d'un
sinon je pense qu'il est noir vont jouer
donc on a joué trop vite cette avance
jusqu'à 3,5 un moment donné et comment
elle est ce qu'elle veut réussir même de
gagner sa vie va jamais daigné faire
peut-être elle va pas perdre et va pas
gagner par contre ils jouent bien mag
nouveau sous cette phase du jour là ce
dernier indice de secours où il est
mille fois mieux que son adversaire
en général on peut dire qu'il sera là et
peut-être un milieu dans les ouvertures
ce que ne pas surprendre mais l'auteur
se débrouillent mieux tant que sage ou
quoi c'était beau mieux non je dirais
qu'en fait là bas si ça ce n'est pas mon
sens juste un petit manque de travail en
fait non pas trop voir sa croissance
il y travaille me tape le tri le travail
plus au 20 heures sur 24 un travail note
est plutôt de même 21 heures sur vingt
quatre
oui mais le problème c'est qu'au savoir
travailler bien cet apparent très
spécial un fait qu'il n'a pas oui c'est
un terrain très spécial c'est tout à
fait à notre part souvent des regards
mais il est même bien
il veut reprendre du cavalier il veut
prendre les maîtres cavaliers là mais là
il va faire tu comprends et damages 6
quand même qu'est le problème son
problème c'est qu'ils sont fous et bien
mort
donc en gros c'est moi je n'ai
difficilement le scénario
il va devenir opérationnel moyen tout ce
que je dis ce n'est les problèmes
sanguins très concret ce qui vous prend
4 2 e et tuvalu est collé ou ce serait
le problème parce que tu vas être obligé
ce qu'il n'y a pas de case en fait non
en fait part à mes juste beaucoup plus
fort aux échecs et les sûrement plus
deux tiers des serments plus doués ça il
y en a aucun doute
donc ce coup d'oeil les tribunaux
damages de [ __ ] en cas d'emprunt de et
tu joues pas dans mon genou faut quatre
dans madoff au judo tour dames aux
doigts et peut-être oui peut-être à 57
ans prend 4 oui madame houdoud en
boudant bouffe au bout et à cinq points
de francs 4 parce que j'ai pas vu en
2005 nous parce que j'ai pas eu assez
voilà et il a fallu absolument ne pas
permettre au besoin de jouer à 5 lorient
7 si non il y en a des chances pour la
forteresse parce que le four huit
apparitions est sûre il ya pas de chance
ici je suis sûre maintenant que ce doit
gagner parce que il va ramener son roi
sur ce 8 après jouer au foot de 7 après
que le wild que vous les 6
et quelque chose de ce genre
il va gagner comme torres fois je crois
que m le français vite la tourache trois
déjà comment parier kavanagh à aller au
matériel fr assistante et donc les
cavaliers de cette seule menace
oui donc couramment e-menaces twh
entourage de son match et c'est ma
d'orage d'autres achats retour 8h du mat
donc ouais
normalement c'est fini les fantoches à
faudrait enfin mécary en cas d'orage
deux jeux 2 jouera à huy où tour à tour
à tour m il s'est planté jeu pareil cas
radio 4 je pense que ça doit gagner à
cet ancien tournoi 6-3 6-7 3/7 trois des
huit tours d'essai 3,8
ouais plus d'échecs avait pris 0,8
ok ok mais il est quand même assez
juvénile un prêt dans son stand où il se
sait un enfant aussi actionnaire non
mais c'est quand même assez
ok je plus de doute sur l'issue du moins
cher fait plus aucun doute je pense que
c'est moi j'ai donc rentrer dans les six
mois
oui où il rencontrera le vainqueur du
match qui jongle et obtient le système
longue et j'aime pas trop s'attendre
pour les blancs ces cas d'un petit 2
fouette sans moi non plus a demandé à ce
que sa voix c'est pas un bon pour
beaucoup comme l'était tout c'est
beaucoup plus intéressant
je trouve cette interview que montrer sa
page il a montré plein de fois sur la
chaîne c'est mon répertoire en fait
parce que là c'est l'ancienne façon de
traiter salle ainsi à la can ce qu'ils
gagnent sur son software jeu ça parce
que c'est pas intéressant mothma donc
qu'est-ce qui va plus on peut dire que
là tu peux faire dans ces deux avec le
défaut et 125 décès c'est déjà plus
intéressant et du coup faire g6 avec les
noirs mais peut-être fou des trois c4
fout d'eux et ça c'est peut-être plus
intéressant fait tout plus intéressant
mais je pense que ici en fait avec les
marges fait cavalier à leur sens bien
sur cette 6 e 5 beaucoup plus fort bien
ce matin même mois regardez les vidéos
de qui vivent avec sébastien joie robin
toronto gier je veux ça c'est excellent
et c'est bouge-toi vous aviez expliqué
tout ce qui au tournant social plutôt
celle qui connaît plutôt c'est moins
marrant au début quand tu m'as pas ni
messi ni pas je regarde personne
je suis pas inscrit pour tâche n excuse
moi mais je les regarde sinon tu as pris
les choses car c'est très intéressant et
je joue je lis comment une foule de
commentaires sur les vidéos avec moi et
puis on me disait je regarde les vidéos
même avec les autres du coup de main une
belle histoire d'amour 2h10 bien sûr
qu'il ait pas d'air est ce que tu
utilises un peu l'île à 0 va encore à
d'ailleurs tiens oui il ya deux jours de
7 depuis toujours gêné huawei
dalila depuis deux jours depuis deux
jours et j'ai stockfisch 10 et loire
depuis deux jours donc j'ai pas rien à
dire pour à présent quand j'avais à dire
quoi que ce soit de subventionner le je
veux vous dire mon avis donc pour
l'instant j'ai rien à dire à temps oui
j'ai beaucoup entendu par rapport à quel
point sélectionnant un toit donc moi je
parle de mon avis encore on nous demande
c'est ch a annoncé des programmes qui
sont open source donc y sont gratuits et
lila les aveugles aux éleveurs sont
gratuits écoutez depuis toujours je
pourrai jamais lire aussi nos chacun à
so foot chelsea stone je sais les six
ans assistante en dessous si heureuse
que je trouve assez excellent esprit là
où ils l'ont acheté plusieurs fois
plusieurs versions est un fan de casse
assistante pas je peux vous dire mes
amis et se parlaient plus au bois ça ses
côtés glory of ans quel que soit ce
moment bien que les bressans quelque
chose c'est mieux qu'ils peuvent par
exemple pour les recherches des parties
j'utilise kinshasa
enfin je sais je sais pas ce que ça
prend quelques secondes laisserait
appris avec archi répit à cherré pied de
prince juste je passe cinq secondes et
j'ai toutes les parties qu'il nous faut
et c'est russe un sérieuses et ils ont
perdu et le regain de concurrence avec
celle prise il ya très longtemps donc
c'est même pas c'est que les russes qui
h st mais le russe continue de ce que ça
et moi y compris
c'est dommage a perdu cette guerre
commerciale a nommé au début des années
90 est cette chose s'impose aux pâquis
au début au milieu des années 90 est
chaud c'est tellement pas croire qu'ils
vont perdre un bras à la fin ils ont
mêlé rouscoff perdent souvent ces règles
là non c'est vrai ces gars là a souvent
toujours toujours non mais tu es dans le
vrai nom comment ils font en fait même
quand ils ont deux produits qui sont
bien ils peuvent
tu sais un autre je sais pas pourquoi je
n'ai pas d'explication non mais ils font
tout le temps ça ah ouais je sais que je
sais que par rapport à la guerre ce
système cette baisse qui était bien sûr
complètement perdu tiens d'ailleurs les
6 et le risque de gagner cela
quoique cette dernière partie monde
radio tellement ses petits copains pour
cet opus marque soit je pense pas qu'ils
voient l'avesnois surtout à 3 marianne à
calais comme lève cette nouvelle édition
mallié auteur jeu blizzard ou sinon j'ai
pas que ça aille surprise il veut
prendre et why et dans 5 mois est ce que
vous 5 et 6 core i5 je peux prendre
social que les recettes que les besoins
que les cinq jeunes et ça il a vu je
pense paraît que ouais
il est forcément
et ne ferment pas va pas répéter les
coups parce qu'il ya plus dur par
rapport à l'issue du match
il offrirait donc droit et en plus un
bon coup juste sur tours à 3
c'est quoi le problème pourquoi elles ne
peuvent pas d'impôts j'arrive pas a
comprendre a peut-être 2,5
je voudrais que vous les bornes mais
qu'elle vient parce que tu peut paraître
un peu cavalier à chaque fois je serai
ok car les bois il menace que venait de
2 est ce qu'il va faire tour à deux ou
trois est ce qu'il va faire l'un d'eux
qui menacent cavaliers b5 et tour d un
mais j'ai moi aussi j'ai le droit pour
un coût actif comme toi huit fosses
hausse est peut-être les parties j'adore
les parties deviennent de plus en plus
besoin de votre soutien
un bon signe en gage commence de donner
le goût
alors étant n'ya pas fou prend et
cavaliers p5 faut broder un bon bien sûr
que vous les poussins ou que relève 5
attend kébé saint qui fait comme en a
ils défendent nous faut maintenant sûr
qu'on réussisse un peu juste pour fait
sûr de ça mais de toute manière je pense
pas qu'il ait millau mais restant ils
pressent déjà les milieux autant mais
ils voient que l'autre commence de
chemistry aussi fait refouler son mac do
trembler la sûreté des saints peut dire
que les trois points
pour l'instant trois bons techniquement
que les trois-quarts laisser ses taux ce
que réussissent ou qu'il soit c'est un
mur puisque les mouvements juillet
comment l'idée de se plaindre et menace
parce que moi je crois que peu d'intérêt
que voler des deux collèges 5 afin de
peut-être viser l'europe l'heure où le
baril
le pape il est calé ses trois par contre
à ok corral et possède comme le précise
et après il va peut-être essayé de
vraiment sur les bio notre offre
c'est quelque chose en fait c'est par al
manar qui veut imac avant la champions
là il avait 3 kilowatts n'a de toute
évidence les bras ne sont pas trop bien
mais il va se faire punir quand même oui
c'est vrai c'est pas toc toc comment il
faut ça se passe il est comme les
recettes soient aussi itunes a même
repris 4 ok ok il en reste que trois
courses dans ok c'est complètement futur
bizarre mais il en avril un vrai studio
que voler à carteret tous a reculé de 3%
ok quand les deux noms pourquoi faire
connaître ou un ensemble qui est
mauvaise technique mais il a trop free
mais qui quoi qui s'est complètement
gagnant du tout premier jeu car ces
trois sociétés
merci mais il a quand même beaucoup trop
frimer parham tient l'auteur ne veux pas
vous donner la tour à eau qui il donne
le tout cas tu aimes ça ça marche
ok + 3 pour
mais il a payé quand même pour il
fallait prendre là nul
et le boulou et le e tailing il a déjà
un poster de toi dans le dans son salon
avec laser mais comme ça blazer je pense
aux propos
après sébastien on l'avait vu à la
soirée qui avait fait le sabre laser
ah tiens et le pet cette fourrière
ça leur plaisait pas très bien c'est
celle où je les dis parce que y voir de
quoi être fier de cette ouverture et les
répéter alors attends je suis un petit
point il reste trente minutes vlad dans
la cadence 3 + 1 donc on a à mi-parcours
du 3 + 1 et après il y aura trente
minutes de bullet tu as pu voir mes
commentaires en bullet merci gamecube le
match il reste encore pas dit si des
c'est bien je suis plus ou moins sûr
qu'il règne un vague a nié mais c'est
bien que ces cures plus trois postulats
mais c'est quand même encore tous sont
arrivés en angola le dirlo paul et même
chose en france on est encore dans le
match en français ok non mais tu peux
dire de ça de manière plus littérale
mais je pense pas il est encore à portée
de fusil quand masculin porté hérésie ah
oui à partir des calculs et les fins on
vous parlait toujours de moi mais qu'est
ce que je fais une chanson à je sais pas
mais je veux le refaire en fait si vous
voulez je trouvais ou faire ça parce que
tachkent dans le fief de motards
première mois à
on peut faire les doux avec ceux dits
voix de leur coeur parce que les au
point pour les dents les dieux pour les
du haut conseil pour les trios et 2 et
moi je dois dire qu'il l'aimait qui
s'occupe du donnera deux enregistrements
je vous avoue un petit secret il est pas
trop cher n'est pas trop cher donc c'est
beaucoup me plus facile à réaliser 5 à
moscou où c'est hyper cher tout ça donc
je pense que je vais refaire une fois je
sais moi je sais pas encore quelle
chanson cne je vois pas ce que je joue
notre foi je voudrais pas que tu sais
qu'on doit chanter une chanson de rap
avec le monteur le monteur ludovic vient
pas et il a écrit une chanson de rap
on doit chanter oui ouais et tu as vu le
texte
je dois lire avec toi en fait gelé sur
l'ordinateur et je dois tu attends pour
le lire à aa
moi aussi d'un modèle gagnant donc ok
j'ai pas aimé comment cette fois ci
comment serna a joué avec libourne ça
parce que carlton adversaire adversaire
marque de l'espace suspense décharge pas
les pièces volontairement mais je pense
qu'il a eu trop de vertige à cause
d'autres succès de l'ouverture qui ont
donc avec la zone rouge six f4 c'est
l'histoire de ne pas voir les aider de
l'intérieur du tout juste ses enfants
ville
ouais enfin tilke ont souvent ceux de
l'est donc j'espère qu'il va perdre
cette fois ci pas que parce que les
mérité mais pour rendre le match plus
chaud vas-y personnel s'il te plaît
patienter
non bien sûr bien sûr rien n'est pas
clair c'est pour ça que je dis que
j'espère je le prévoir nos pages
j'espère juste parce que bien sûr
lorsque les blancs aux nantais un pion
sur 2,4 lorsque les doigts en dentelle
chaussures
je 2 qui est brouillé par 2,5 années là
ont bien sûr qu'un valet de 4,3 à vie
bien sûr c'est toujours chaud et surtout
quand c'est un acquis non mais tu sais
c'est marrant parce que peut-être f3 et
non g8 qui avaient les deux os très
possible l'armée regarde comment j'ai
bien calculé d'envoi 5 sata pas calculer
mais désolé pas de choix par contre
peut-être tout re cavaliers de 2 juste
un prête nom avant tout autre barricade
collet de deux heures et toi ou trois
tours j'étais moche et non ça marche pas
non plus donc non africains à l'épreuve
ou la ola leurs ouailles bois d'angers -
f2f géraud h3 algeria d'un match 2-0
tour intermédiaire oui c'est surtout
j'évite tout huit cloud notre douleur
est après tout ajouté après tant de oi
non mais ok il est bon parent très doué
oui très doué
waouh
comme cyril je prends sur moi je pense
que m quel score du poison rémy et
ouvriers le second énorme je suis pas
sûr que cela aurait gagné une possible
il aurait pris très cher
je pense que ce serait plus hautes et 1
sec mais qui est peut-être maxime aurait
un peu baissé à mon année mais sinon oui
ça a été très asséché n'était pas
inquiet des prépas de mvl pour demain
j'ai très peur en fait moi je sais pas
mais c'est une question principale parce
que cette dernière table à y livrer son
confit recommence de souffrir mais je
craque beaux arts
peut-être une petite crise aussi mais ce
n'était pas un compteur qui joue quand
même parce que les gens devant le tchad
vous voulez que je devienne son second
dans la dernière fois ok ce n'est qu'une
question d'éventuelles déjà et il me l'a
jamais proposé j'ai déjà prié tous donc
c'est un peu tôt pour parler de ce qu'on
demande pour ouvrir ce qu'on parlait de
mon atterrissage sur le marché ce n'est
qu'ils ont des ventes il était torride
pourquoi l'avoir pourquoi pataugeoire
france bah quoi je fais confiance à pam
ans plus tard semble à panama qui veut
dernier trois dames aucun vêtement
bien sûr il est nettement mieux non mais
c'est que si c'est un exemple classique
quand le cavaliere nettement plus fort
que le fou parce que il est bloqué dès
2003 d'embrasser les briquets vous voyez
donc avec lourdeur des coûts très
souvent par rame réussit quand même de
prouver à son adversaire qui ont l'idée
principale de ce thon buri quelle est
l'idée principale question à part de
gagner de l'espace
c'est avec la chaîne des pions
réussissent f5 de 5
c'est l'histoire de brooke et le fougeux
deux convois dans le côté les biens de
leur côté les mauvais parce que
n'oubliez pas que si on les formules de
capablanca c'est la meilleure façon de
prouver qu'il nous foute adversaire est
mauvais c'est du boîtier avec les pions
sur le même
c'est pour ça des fois les gens tu sais
quand tu quand tu prends des joueurs
amateurs
on y comprennent pas pourquoi des fois
on met les pions sur la couleur du foie
adverse
c'est pas facile à comprendre ça on sait
un autre concept d'eau voilà donc les
linkers tous les plus ordinaires d'après
les auteurs américains mais tactiquement
il est très forte a vu à chaque fois il
y avait des pointes et ou quoi nan mais
regarde faveur s'est passé quand même du
travail d'orfèvre non c'est très propre
campagne très près ce qu'ils accueillent
que des seconds
non ok c'est un peu moi je referais la
blessure à un moment donné le collier
voit faire une fourchette parce que
lorsqu'un acte de ce combat c'est
impossible d'éviter les forêts du
colonel sauf qu'au hockey à tour de cinq
coureurs 4 du bien numéro le cadre
direct si mais c'est tellement dur de
trouver trois ici bas et le haut poste
ok mais là on peut pas prendre des
revenants trouve à encore mieux
est-ce qu'il peut essayer de gagner ça
non il va perdre non ça va moi c'est de
revoir machin mieux ils vont faire
juvénile ou pas non sauf qu'ils ont
peut-être pas me tuer du temps non et
tuer le temps n'ont pas manqué qui le
sauvetage miraculeux
incroyable non ok bravo night of bricks
et qu'est ce qu'ils vont nous jouer
encore faut 2 avec les dh quatre
épreuves en tout cas tant mieux pour
l'intérêt du match là parce que ces
trois points ça reste faisable dessin
bon normalement c'est pas trop bien
sache pas de calais de cinq ans les 2,5
foot de 5 c 4
je vote pour ce 4 mai sur freud en tout
genre ou d'android tour jean et j'ai par
exemple faire fukatsu g6 ils sont fous
rires et fils
bon peut-être raison marche 5 c'est
encore plus besoin
attias il justement loges où l'adq est
ce que ce fonds émanant c400 ce france -
voix près fourgeaud qu'il y aura aussi
des pertes et des idées avec
intermédiaire ou quatre échecs un
surpoids par contre yahoo 4 peut-être
c'est pas un bon coup mais pourquoi pas
oui on nous demande si parent peut tenir
tête à fuir ou déjà non bon sans aucun
doublon et aprilia y'a pas photo
fil rouge est intraitable et par ramon
blitzkrieg américaine incroyable il a
que 16 ans non il est brillant bien sûr
bien sûr les brillants mais ça se voit
tout de suite c'est même pas la peine de
voir ce parti en glisse et il suffit de
voir ce parti un classique pour
comprendre à qui a mal à faire sauf que
maintenant c'est le moment le plus dur
qui arrive hein parce que arriver
jusqu'à 2007 lorsque tsi douée jaune
c'est une chose devenir un joueur
d'élite c'est une autre chose rester en
tant qu un joueur d'élite c'est une
autre chose et puis après il ya d'autres
qui seront encore est ce que tu as peur
que si il n'y avait pas non il joue bien
là et le jeu bien qu'il est le mieux est
maintenant les questions c'est que
valait 1 5 qui arrive donc fou 10,6
il faut absolument que le 5 mai je pense
qu on chez les jaunes il ya un problème
récurrent c'est l'absence de de
l'attention aux idées de ton envers
servait comme le centre car les trois
bien sûr tout de suite tu rentres dans
cette finale parce que tu vas pas les
perdre donc au lieu de cela bien sûr
foutu 6 parce que dans ce cas là le
cavalier et pris note de cette
possibilité
pourquoi le tour est vite comme le 104e
je vais pas ces gamins c'est logique
mais bon quel 5 à 3 et 2 pourquoi pas
maintenant ce sont cinq tours de retour
d'air et les noirs sont nos règles
claires si vous mélangez 5,6 à attaquer
la casse des huit ça permettait de
nombreux étudiants comme gagné 7,7
colada colonnes est-ce que deux tours
h55 ou ici
bon sauf que maintenant si hockey petit
talibans sont encore millau mais leur
nombre est possible qu'il y ait eu quoi
que
une fois les voir mettre le retour sûr à
100 qu'il est noir mettre le retour sur
jouer des joueurs fournissent était
alors au fossat qu'encore et s'enlève
toutes les questions et maintenant c'est
la question c'est s'il est blanc rouge
pour 4 et le noir le noir doivent
prouver qu'ils ont ils pu recréer du
coup la cdu contre joue sur les droits
des commandes c'est une question il faut
utiliser le calme - où le mettre elle
nous plaît pas à chaque fois tu le mets
quelque part je fous de 4 quoique
peut-être c'est pas une tragédie
mais sur les six bien sûr au rire à
détricoter 4 mio bien sûr ok là
maintenant il vit cette case l'est
peut-être accepter plus facile à voir
carrément qu'un hyper un pion quand même
il faut de troyes aube bourbourg bouffe
2e cat fou de quatre échecs et 3 c'est
un peu dommage mais je peux y faire fi
des quatre échecs avant mais ça va
perdre mon hockey normalement les
finales les futurs jeux sous je pense
moi il faut prouver en quoi moi j'aurais
pas joueuse ce sens que si moi je réfute
aussi natale le garder et pourquoi pas
prêt 5 parce que j'ai toujours peur de
tâches des trucs comme ça
toujours plus et je pense que j'ai
raison est ce que tu fais à 5 c'est fini
la majorité elle est morte
ok ils veulent ils view il va jouer
peut-être tout aaa avec les droits de
41.5 mesure vous obsède wabush de
fouilles et de nouveaux tu te pose les
questions qu'ils idiot tu es qui ont pas
respecté
les règles données par m le pion sur
laquelle on se croit dans le clip de
record deux fois non mais c'est ça en
fait c'est qui le regarde pas assez les
idées des adversaires mais ils font des
coups brillants de temps en temps on
pense que le sourire parce qu'ils sont
brillants mouais encore toujours reste
toujours présent dans leur approche
surtout ok ça m'étonnerait si serena va
perdre à 100 parce que depuis longtemps
mais la paille ou des lbo position c'est
pas que les millions mais au moins la
motte-tilly les respirer qui a noté que
c'est par am qui a pas trop de temps à
dire je veux dire je n'ai pas fait gaffe
au sein du cochon sahara n'a essayé de
gagner là
ok gagner moi qui organise ne peut pas
gagner ce juste tu peux pas parce qu'au
petit que moi les c'est toujours les
bois qui reste muet là maintenant ils
vont matériaux tous sont fous sur quatre
après quoi elle peut pas perdre même
éventuellement mais quoi qu'ils aient
pas gagné mais manieca loges jeudi les
maniaques
il brille lillers gagner quand même de
chrome os est ce qu'ils ont avec un pion
de plus est dans une position
complètement nul et une voix juste
bouger les pièces oui
d'un côté ils le font de notre côté il
est dieu et le temps c'est plutôt en
faveur de l'autre aqmi opère le bien ok
normal donc mes amis ne répétait jamais
de telles fautes comme ce sacre de la
bardot parham jamais torah et boussens à
cela parce que tout ça a été défendue
pour le four 3 donc il n'ya pas de
possibilités tactiques qui apparemment
fair play ce qu'il aurait pu faire une
bonne soupe
voyez aulas il répète toujours les mêmes
fautes des cordes amos est là il reste
deux parties normalement cette cadence
folle cas d'un mauvais coup maintenant
fut f4 géré petit rock fou de cette
fouille huit fois aux mondiaux prévoyez
de ces eaux là ils vont te tuer non on
en met les hommes il faut il faut
connaître car même les grands classiques
nes alcoa versa voilà ce dont les doigts
recommande d'acheter des livres de ce
que c'est c'est parmi les choses les
plus classiques pour stewart
une fois les voir jouer frappe qui vous
effraient intérieur photo c'est fort ça
les noirs ne sont pas mieux moulinois de
gens ne sont pas au monde et cette
chanson après que valeo 4 après la tour
lips sur m6 et m6 tu penses que les
livres lus superbe son bien pour ça mais
ça s'est expliqué dans tous les gros
livres de l'école soviétique mais de
telles choses oh là là mais bon je
compte je comprends très bien que je
parle qu un vieux comme un vieux
classique guitare classique
on appelle ça un vieux con français
[Rires]
excusez moi voir ça s'appelle pavlov vie
au classique c'est vrai j'aime bien les
mairies
c'est quoi ce tombeau le principe de ces
questions et on voit le mont anis l
épisode m56 de 5e 6e telle formation des
pions il ya deux raisons pour première
l'espace deuxième tué le four jeu deux
en fait
malheureusement pour nous les français
et heureusement pour moi l'heureuse il y
avait un article excellent écrit par
chronique quelque part au début des
années 90 sur ce ton bois sur les
principes de ce tournoi il y avait que
deux mois et veut pas de rien presque
presque mais je ne pense pas que cet
article il existe en français ou en
anglais
moi je les loue en heureuse d'ailleurs
c'est murtha ce qui m'a fait remarquer
c'est particulier les excellentes il est
doué crise où nous tous tout moment y
compris fou de cette fuite
ok je savais ce que jamais pour ceux qui
savent pas mon par mois donc ceux qui à
quoi que vous pouvez utiliser google
translate construire donc trouvé cet
article un russe était dans quel
magazine 64 je sais pas parce que je
vais sur internet je l'ait pas vu avant
trouverez cet article traduisait le
heller vous allez tout comprendre sur ce
qu'on roule parce que s'il ya quelqu'un
qui sait expliquer les choses au chèque
c'est bien
big boi moi c'est yves logghe will be
blood mais tu as pas mis dans les génies
comment tu n'as pas mis dans la liste
des génies s'il ya quelqu'un qui
sûrement pas gêner ses chroniqueurs t'es
sûr fera bien sûr bon ça
archi doit en très très grande
philosophe n'est pas uni d'ailleurs je
pense que les jeunes y songe en effet
l'association son génie je regarde mais
est-ce que tu connais ans où ils furent
sauve qui a été considéré comme j bhl je
vois qu'il gilmour où il convient de moi
je le sors je dis vous pas que les gens
disent nietzsche ouais on n'est pas le
seul ni le génie dans le sens qu'il
était fou bon peut-être peut-être moins
marqué que deux fois cette dame c'est 2
qui est des cinq courses et 6 kg 3
tu veux dire que tu es pas fini sauf si
j'ai bien compris
non mais ici quelque part les noirs
doivent les noirs doivent être mieux
bien sûr parce que toutes les fautes par
les doigts on organise
je pense que leurs jeunes aux corvées
terme a assez bien très bientôt je serai
assez bien trop parce que prophylactique
non mais c'était pas mal fois justice
quoi il ya toujours du oui pour les
dépasser ou les volumes étant de placer
la regarde les cinq joueurs d'ailleurs
faux bouffe tour je serais fait mais
peut-être il a le temps pour watch nommé
week-end une chose est claire c'est
michael frais c'est clair moi je pense
que peut-être en cours à l'asile ou
alors si ce rôle si c'est suffisant -
parents voient sûrement trouver quelque
chose de plus intéressant au cayrol
l'école père roule bien sur vous c'est
85 toujours niçois bars belges le droit
ok vous avez le droit - the no to lunch
donc je vous vois je veux pas vous
contredire hockey qui viennent commenté
réduire mais demain je recommençais
partie des 5 france o ainsi tous deux
parce qu'il doit à faire clair et b4
dance 3 et au g7
attendu le bio meilleur à peut-être
encore voilà ce que tu veux dire y'a
peut-être à 3 encore à mais ok mais là
c'est facile n'ont manqué tout juste
vrai g8 à toi je vais tout ce qu'elle
voit revenir cet été mais je me trompe
ou pas ils pouvaient gagner une pièce
avec coussin ouais ce moment-là basics
ouais nan presse pour savoir quel tour
ces trois fois oui ou non mais vous
promets à une en juillet 2007 mais
s'attendent au vieux retraités aux
québécois quoique 12,7 au dôme c6 est un
moment donné peut-être il faudra
reboucher les papilles virage 7 ou alors
faire h45
quelle conception
par contre c'est pas si facile de
matières connaissent pas mouais les
blues vont être sous cette menace
jusqu'à la fin mais regardez s'inquiète
rude contre je ne sais quoi les deux
bouts de match je pense qu'il y en a ok
il veut faire tour jean dame f3 est ce
que c'est possible ou parier dès 7 h 3
ton jeu de gagne ou pas d'enfants sur ma
part oui pour ses 7 90 être les bouffes
g7 et on joue et on gère dans ce cas là
il est sauté avec way at yani les dom
pour le second ok mais il ya tanger 6 à
1 sinon il est truqué ok moi le grès que
c'était pas clean clean
il a fait le mode promis comme un vrai
mais je pense qu'il y avait des défenses
et 10 de saut à skis aussi en guerre
ok si vous la voulez ou considérés en
tant que fellah sauf peut-être mais moi
je le considère plutôt comme l'était
mais non en fait il a dit ne sait mais
il est vrai n'était pas loin de deux
génies peut-être été un génie parce que
déjà elle était épileptique et je sais
connu que c'est le maladie de génie mais
césar était utile et personne ne doute
que ça a été génial quand tu peux être
un philippe tic c'est bien jailli
pourquoi moi toute ma vie je rêve de
triplé petit peu malheureusement non
malheureusement je pars oil heureusement
plusieurs fois j'ai tenté je tentais
même j'avais pas mal hors du coup à il
veut faire payer fait refouler de hockey
comme d'hab
par amour monde ses connaissances
profondes l'ouverture pour dire
l'absence totale de connaissance donc à
sa demande à ses ventes heures sur 24
consacré aux échecs qu'est-ce qu'il fait
exactement
peut-être c'est pas vrai parce que c'est
vrai je t'ai dans le même avion n'avait
cru moscou astana
je vais vous parler je le veux dormir je
les veux manger je pense qu'il travaille
20 heures par 24
je vends 4 c'est fou je pense que tu
comprends ce que je veux c'est fou non
travailler autant mais elle se demande
qu'est-ce qu'il fait exactement parce
qu'ils répètent les mêmes fautes de les
ouvertures avec le doigt avec les
besoins
il connaissait pas cette ligne enfin
parmi les plus grognons donc ses
connaissances et j'ai une nouvelle
mémoire n'ont jusque là pas de système
pour travers les ouvertures et personnes
et pilonnés par contre y dany qui est
peut-être le moindre permis cette
génération brillant dernière c'est un
très bon thierry tic en effet ruz a
parfois est très bien dans les airs sur
parce que quelqu'un qui les aident fil
rouge à m j'ai l'impression que firent
usa travail avec qu'ils cadrent pas seul
mais avec quelqu'un à ce sérieux parents
bien sûr pas du tout il devenir
peut-être de régis dur pour travailler
les ouvertures
ouais ben apparemment ok on voit que
tout juste naturel tout et que oui mais
c'est peut-être sais pas si tu as
pourtant très réouverture
si tu seras et 20 heures par jour j'ai
regardé analyses tu comprends ok moi je
n'y au tube tu as ta base de données tu
regardes les variantes ouverte de
l'espagnol tu regarde tout ce qui existe
et nous allons leur flotte
il demande la cellule la cie nul les six
nuls
ok you knew les eaux 25e coup le trio
35e de celui qu'est ce que tu fais là
nice est de comprendre qu'à bahreïn par
variante justement là le problème c'est
que il y en a sur dans cette situation
quand les variantes
mais n'allez nulle et l'ordinateur et la
montre partout il y aura ce que kid à
cette situation la trouve des idées qui
sont dures à réfuter sur l'échiquier
il y en a ceux qui peuvent juste
regarder légaux existants et les
relations et qu'ils réfléchissent pas
par eux-mêmes qui arrivent pas eu moyen
de trouver un concept du mans duo a
réfuté a réfuté sur l'échiquier
ce sont en fait les différences entre
les uns et les autres
en fait il y en a ceux qui peuvent faire
ce qu'ils peuvent pas et en fait ce que
se crispe ont même pas apte à force il y
en a des mecs créatif qui ne sont pas
trop voir mais qui en vend des milliards
d'aidés de leur vie il y en a de très
forts qui arrive pas kriens eux ce sont
en fait c'est tout un peu en avant tout
à fait différent ok qu'est ce que tu
pourrais m'en il en retient plusieurs le
foot pro f 4 dans le stonewall dont le
fou preuve qui a donc sonné il aurait pu
connaître ça ou ça bien sûr c'est juste
c'est juste
d'où le savoir comment comment
travailler le hockey de toute manière qu
est-ce qui en a donc je pense que les
positionner plus ou moins légales afin
d'y apparaître trois qui font ces cinq
ici comme en f3 qui prend ses cinq as
peut-être c'est juste un gars non c'est
encore raté les jeux d'un métier c'est
juste une question d'habitude c'est déjà
un coup à se mouiller dont on comprend
donc pas les réseaux intelligents quand
affluent sur blanc tu vas voir la barre
des 4 salles et des fossés capte foutent
de sacrées et pour l'instant je ne vois
pas de réfutation
même si ça donne l'impression que rien à
voir ouais je ne vois pas put être
corrélé à st
aya 382
bon alors c'est ça la lah résultats sion
et wes à des poursuites au civil tour
des quatre avec eux - pas à l'adoption
de plus clean clean bien que j'ai fait
ça mais c'est mort ok dame 6% seulement
voilà le signe de paul mc do de la
classe c'est plutôt le signe de ma
technique de la fatigue je pense parce
que d'un monsieur c'est juste un coût de
1 8 10 ans donc et une blague maintenant
bien sûr c'est bien foutu
ici il va gagner ça va être plus 5 ce
que peut être rédhibitoire
je connais pas le sens macé lors que
c'est fini quoi normalement oui mais
c'est la dernière partie puisque ça en
attaque red bull est avec cinq points
d'écart aurait c'est beaucoup ok petit
peu en a qu'un qui sait je vois pas qui
est son style correspond bien aux joues
de poulet je vois pas il est trop
classique
il est il ce pas surprendre il se pare
chocs et son adversaire avec des
confiseurs
il joue au jour tu as assez prévisible
et pas trop fois donc il va pas égalisé
donc non pas ramer juste nettement plus
fort mes amis sauf usa vertus hommage à
bruce pour les ponts et il change tout
le temps
c'est plus tard ce que peut-être elle
explique que sa force il sait que c'est
de la musique ça donne de la motivation
est toute chose je sais que clairement
cette dernière jour là je faisais matin
hier quand il met les radios surtout
musique l'accès à leur look 100 c'est
mille fois plus facile aux pacers passer
sa torture leur ok mais il fait mater en
deux camps avaient conséquent sur le
podium juste mauvais c'est fou quoi pas
plus 5
ça fait mal là dans ses mains la
dernière partie 2
c'était la dernière saillie la dernière
donc on fait une petite pub n'hésitez
pas à flots la chaîne on revient dans 5
minutes pour les bullet à tout
[Musique]
quand les mecs ça risque de reprendre
d'une seconde à l'autre
je plaide pas trop de suspense pour
cette fin de match malheureusement oui
malheureusement oui
la femme du de 3,3 c'était plus ou moins
la marche triomphale de barack ne vois
pas de perspectives pour égalisation
éventuel parce que paraît-il que sarah
est juste moi fois et en plus je pense
que comme tu l'avais dit plus tôt c'est
la cadence qui va le plus favorisé par
un oui parce que dans les positions aux
régionales tant qu'il s'agit de switch
pour son propre cerveau par ramsey
d'hébreu à chaque fois mieux
ouais et sarnaks en plus à du manoir
milieu les tactiques ados balle il est
il
il voit de tactique semble donc enfin il
a tout pour gagner ce match d'une
manière convaincante au quai de nouveau
et en faisant cet annuaire d'ailleurs je
pense que serena est la faute qu'ils ont
s'il a une position marche pas si on ne
va rien ne marche pas au mieux même si
tu obtiens une bonne position au milieu
de ce week-end au mieux de changer parce
que si ça marche pas ça marche pas là
donc là encore il est varié à l'obtenir
il a rien obtenir déjà je préfère une
loi reste donc ça va passer bien terminé
oui bien sûr cartographe dommage car sa
mairie mais c'est juste qui comprend pas
trop juste au nord il est vrai qu'on
prend juste part il
il connaît pas trop les théories il
comprend pas le sens de ce qui ne l'est
déjà notre maman bien ok eu des mois
j'ai pris très bien surtout il faudra
jouer ici devant les pions c'est à vous
comme budget 5 car il va toujours aussi
bien sûr tout possible un peu je retour
à 5 3 6
pas mal d eau d intéressant dia que le
noir qui peuvent espérer de gagner ça ne
vois pas comment quoique après 2005 ces
gars-là fait - il est au lieu de cela le
feu dans le h4 mais voilà tu peux faire
si tu joue vraiment mal contre le
landais tu peux faire ce que je fais du
feu 4b 404 week end
si tu sais pas quoi offrir contre la
hollande est une faute et 4 5% et blois
justice je vous fais de toi
l'autre fois fou je sais tu fait coller
ces trois inquiétudes tout juste
oui et puis par exemple tu peux te ra
qui est bon à jeter retail être
remboursés marche pas je pensais qu'ils
auraient tourcoing h 4 et quelque chose
comme ça à faire une petit nul qui s est
une boulette bien sûr donc critiquons
pas trop bien sûr ok c'est pas clean
clean comme on dit ça mais ok là on va
pas critiquer parce que là il s'agit
surtout d'un ce pacte de de voir des
trucs à d'opale plutôt que je connais
toi tu ressens que dans nos six je pense
que c'est possible a pas à comprendre
pourquoi il est 10h ce qu'il a perdu
dans la colonne un fait oui madame f 4
tours 5
ah ok parce que touré silva repère le
pion c63 de sept patients âgés certes
parce que les boissons milieu déjà l'air
de boissons de 3000 ici précise un v6 et
d'éleveurs sont foutus d'heure ça s'est
très très mal joué les derniers coups de
enfin tous ces trois là si si si
peut-être tout gagné 7,6 je pense de la
smat bon ce foutu parce que juste de
menaces pattes
ok donc amenés à les cerner allez tu
penses tu veux revenir j'espère bourreau
pour
pour que ce soit plus intéressant pour
la patrie non food peut être
complètement complètement en live à
gagner mouais l'autre voiture jusqu'au
bout maintenant bien sûr pour des
raisons assez évident ouais sur ce qui
peut se permettre duclos tu l'as fait
donc on pourra même pas dire que ce
n'est pas fair-play quoi ça va faire un
point pour pour le joueur russe
championne si on arrivait comme moi où
j'ai joué jusqu'à la franche prix bien
sûr mairie tout cas ainsi que des revues
et louis mais pas à 5h dommage qu'il n'a
pas su agen parce que sur l'achat qui
avaient un coût très intéressante c'est
déjà bien froid et pour utiliser les gaz
de 5
ok je connais pas trop cette ligne là
vrai dire dans ma 5
je trouve bizarre mais je vais faire
rock ici à doha 306 que le cap que le 4
x 4 0 pour bush que les dessins quelques
compensations
ok mais je pense que j'ai compris en
fait à chaque fois par un vieux seule
chose veut mettre son fou sur l'octroi
la tour sur un an
et puis le cavalier sur f5 et donc et en
voyant ainsi jouer un jour pour un tacle
d'ailleurs elle est très belle et très
bonne approche en fait parce que bien
sûr le cavalier et 50 blitz c'est déjà
peut-être 0,50
mais au niveau de l'évolution
parce que le corps n'est sûr absent que
il est la tendance de mater dans les
classes de partis classiques souvent
prises surtout un être cher j4h 4g 5 et
chassait le cavalier 2,5 avec 2,6 ramène
de corée sur q3 où les bio place est ok
là maintenant on va voir la bouche aussi
d'une manière ou d'une autre et le voir
et thermales dans le dos reis 2
tous deux que les trois gars du matos de
jeu qui lui aurait prononcé juste
marquer les trois conseils juice camping
se passe sans rire bien sûr au hockey
c'est très agréable
ok mais c'est des fois qu'on ya
plusieurs tactiques qui marche et envoie
une tu cherches pas une autre ambulance
jusqu'à moi comme andy et moi nous lasse
caire si vous voyez un bon coup ne nous
fait pas chercher encore meilleur un mur
parce que souvent elles existent donc
vois je vais de conversys il faut
comprendre à leurs commandes défendent
d'abord moi j'évite cavalière 6 je
prends à tient dans des villes moyennes
sections j'ai pas lu ça je pars ça donc
c'est pas du tout les fondements donc
maillot dans la poche donc le hockey on
en est là ok normal moi c'est perdre en
moi il faut montrer les techniques à moi
j'ai déjà pu faire avoir je dois euros
et fuite
la nature elle fit et maintenant ils à
tourcoing f2 qui arrive avec fouille
cinq échecs iphone 4 d'ailleurs un peu
pour ça il va monter vers h4 non là il
n'a pas pris en exil à fait fou et cinq
échecs intermédiaire il a cru qu'il
était malin il ajuste fils un pion mais
c'est du bled va d'ailleurs elle ne
menace pas que voler f6 malheureusement
pour des raisons multiples y compris
pour hadopi 3
ok donc lancée intéressante parce que
c'est facile de lever le tabou c'est tu
dois faire ça quand les gens font je me
sens ok mais là tu dois quand même aux
arcades
tu dois quand même un moment donné faire
parce qu'il a fallu au moins 3 / h
quatre fois sur 1 2 il était caché leurs
ailes il n'a pas caché et il fait quoi
avec ses échecs en fait donc il faut
baudoux hk intéressés ok c'est rama à
l'intérêt de
ils sont partis rapidement parce que ils
voient pas les gagner celle-là vas-y
bouturage quand je suis au torse et 6
seraient où tout se sait
faire tout et ouais ils échangent les
toits ouais quand il est sympa le pam
full swing et donc le score blatty ainsi
à 10,1 pouces ton boule c'est toujours
plus 4 et il reste 21 une minute 42
laddh
donc c'est faisable ce faisable
allez allez à saratov cerrato vous c'est
la ville de serre n'a donc je pense pas
que je me trompe donc c'est pour ça que
je parle toujours tout ça c'est la ville
de rien de s'être sinon serratos et la
ville de domont jusque là rien de celle
c'est pas du tout les ans fc
tcheliabinsk
ah oui c'est la pièce chrome secours
donc il a fait et partage sa vie
intérieure de hockey donc papillon mais
compensation parce que votre coup
laurent blanc bien sûr c'est toujours en
compensation sans aucun doute il m même
si les lois peuvent être un peu moins
bien il est plus facile de jouer avec
les doigts néanmoins s'il ya ceux qui
comme toujours que pas que ampoule est
en prison général mais en plus on
voulait surtout de permettre la collecte
des sacs avec les déclins p6 il faudra
bouger soir la tour soit la barre de fer
la danse le temps sera sec mais la dame
soit 5 c'est logique mais là il commence
à car il va revenir en b 4 filiales
embrigader les hommes étaient offerts à
4,1 d'avoir fait reculer au qatar il va
faire rage six à new york six par
semaine pour oublier le problème qui va
il va peut-être mettre près la demande
des cinq
c'est toujours agréable de jouer avec le
noir même s'ils sont moins justement
tout simplement parce que tu peux bouger
les pieds sans réfléchir avant tu ne
sais pas moins bien que moi rien le truc
qui est bien à adja ça c'est pénible
hassan nasrallah pénible est justement
celle le vertige créé par trop de succès
qu il aime autant bien sûr c'est bien
foutu
si le défaut à six secondes c'est plus
ou moins sûr en fait c'est complètement
sion pour ses 75
mais voici déjà les purs ou le voici en
caisse il s'est même pas la peine de
calculer
bien sûr ce gain ok ça va être plus
trois passes à bien chauffer la ddt
ça devient chaud ça devient très chaud
ok tour de 4 2 à 4
après quoi on peut y avait peut-être
dans neuf salles a réussi c'est bien
raconté la même seconde a trait aux six
tout de suite au lieu de quatre tours de
rete gas a gagné +3 allez allez auquel
reviendra ce premier amoureux mais il
faut que parce qu apparemment parce que
s'ils continuent la descente ada aux
enfers ça peut mal se passer quoi
trois points c'est plus grand chose sur
la vie de trois points à l'école et
précises comme les seins à sa femme anne
ok ça joue très mal bien sûr parler de
noir mais ok avant pas critiquer ça les
poulettes mois jojo nettement moins bien
que de tous je sais pas jouer une
boulette c'est dur c'est complètement
différent que le bis
moi je peux pas et tu sais quand tu
t'entraînes a bien joué en blitz tu
régresse en bullet c'est assez
spécifique comme truc auquel le noir on
enterrait de mettre leurs dames sur ce
oui il faut pas au pérou douter le truc
qu'on pouvait trouver pas quoique valeur
de 7
ça m'étonnerait pas si le noir perd
quelque chose de force
ouais on sait si oui si tous souhaitent
céder
donc les noirs ont déjà perdu depuis ses
six salles plus intimes apprécié que
valeo sa 2e quoique peut-être assez
linéaire chose que les deux 5e sac de
dans le sens parce que se dresse et
malheureusement intolérable quand le e6
avec les défauts du sein ou avec des 2 4
et 2 5 qui est parti là malheureusement
savoir être plus qu'avant inquiète
jusqu'à ça fait mal puisque ça fait mal
pelade ok ça y est
trop de mentos quand le set 7 fawcett
moi moi je gagne à six mois moins de
boulettes à ses filles mais là peut-être
intérêt à abandonner ce qui fait qu il
est là ça fait toujours quatre points
d'écart vlad
il reste 17 minutes mais s'il te plaît à
votre page de trois fous je 12.4 mais
s'il te plaît à dire ça c'est la faute
par contre si les variantes des raisons
du succès tu le changement parce que je
joue c'est con parce que déjà l autre
sens ça montre que l'auteur sait pas
comment traiter et ses psychoses et
coucy et ça c'est ça a été les votes
quand même au niveau du choix de
voitures après tout c'est parfois en bus
lettre comme tu joues vie tu t'oublies
juste mais parfois c'est juste le monde
ouais je comprends et rauque et bien sûr
c'est une mauvaise version que les
variantes leningrad pour le noir après
2,5
bien sûr normalement les bourgs noir
peuvent pas permettre autant de choses
au point précise que les poudres mais
qu'est ce que tu fais là quoi mais tu
veux toujours être bull est quand même
quelqu'un tu vises l'activité mais il
veut jouer pépère pour la casse des 5
oui la position de vino stable et
constat auquel est déjà un peu mieux
annoncé mort failli sa fille mais il
aimait pas mieux les mondiaux pts s'il
permet de 5 2 3 ok tout ce que tu te
fous de 5 c d e f
c'est un bon avantage pour le droit et
ce cas table où tant pis si ce cadre ef
d'imbéciles et ce cadre avec un secteur
en très bon avantage le noir le plus 5 +
5 ha oui je pensais que je les ai reçus
cinq sur l'ordi déjà davantage ça c'est
quoi c'est plus 150 sas
ouais au souk ici c'est plus de support
les doigts sont complètement final c'est
foutu et non plus 5 s'est finie en fait
bon en fait part à mme il a juste un peu
ralenti au début parce que moi tu meurs
vaut mieux d'abandonner maintenant et
essayer de gagner le prochain puisque
ici de toute manière tu vois pas sa
mosquée d'alger 5 jan il reste quoi il
reste combien de temps il reste 15
minutes 15 minutes ça fait cinq parties
à oued près cinq parties max peut-être
même pas annoncé mort à vlad le
ressortissant de saratov en sueur à
saratov en sueur paterno mois dès les
chronos parce que matador jane do g6 se
sent tous rachetés par forêts raciale
vous rappelle que les diplômes aussi bon
à temps il peut peut-être la sauver
voici en kiosque s il vous plaît s'il
encaisse tout est encore possible d'un
match 2 ils menacent m'attendais quand
même
il va faire pousser 8
ok mais il y en a deux tours bobcat ok
mais peut-être pas grave tout rejet un
propos
ok la panique ce type d'objet en maths
mais tour jean c'était peut-être pas mal
qui elle rigole déjà lassé finir et
maintenant ça joue plus haut taux pour
le meneur de jeu que trois petits rock
d'un mode heures ou quand le saint comme
il est de 7 g mépris des lois n'a jamais
dans ma vie j'aurais pris ce souffle
différent régate des quatre jamais fait
boîtes noires le garage 3 f4e tapage 3
parce que [ __ ] titulaire de la classe
pour le fou en tout cas c'est une
méthode ruiz ce qu'on appelle en
français comme ça je sais qu'il appelle
comme ça qu'on l'appelle comme ça toi tu
appelles ça comment déjà wikio qu'est
google ou yahoo qui soutiennent qu il y
avait un moteur tchèque je pense qu'ils
jouent se tient le mât des noirs sont de
nouveau mieux parce qu'il nous faut se
retrousser quelque chose à voir si ce
n'est qu'elle vous a vu hydro mais là
les vents ils sont mal peut-être farkash
de g4 non non je pense que de toute
évidence tout ce qu'il veut il juste
attendre attendre
il est vrai il est dur de craquer se
pose que faust et fort bon je critique
pas je joue encore moins bien ça voilà
le truc c'est que ça va trop vite pas
pour faire des bons coups
ce sans rajout du temps une seconde mais
c'est peu sur un vrai chic et aurait
bien joué mais il tient pas mal en fait
avec les blancs ouais parce que le tout
autrement
finalement mais la tour ans et 4 %
maintenant que tous les héros apparaît
presque faire d'amd cette loi pierre de
cela les voitures de cela chez noir
entre va pas gagner
ok il revit quand même
ok mais un peu pas perdre un seul
du coup rien à voir nous faut tous fous
pour quelques fois un peu plus facile de
jeu avec après cette partie ce sera
gagnant mathématiquement ce sera
vraiment sûr que les noirs que sarah ne
peut pas revenir si la gagne pas ok
jusque là ces genres 99% mais ce sera se
rendre pour cent il va bouffer je
suppose
bon bref cinq ans par alain joseph a
tout à fait guéri ses cinq d'abord ok
tout reprend il faut prendre il faut
prendre les 5 tours 5
walsh histoire à no 1 a bien joué 5 à 3
4 il va gagner
oui le voir que c'est les deux bios
ouais il encaissa le chantier des quatre
regagner très heureux provoqueront des
supers heures et au g4 et au f4 regardez
aguichante de partout
bref 4 il va faire ce soir
on parie non non ok mais c'est tellement
agréable de bouger de cette position là
c'était deux sociétés noir au la brique
watts de quoi après griffiths c'était
l'idée avec le détour dude acquis torah
je suis trop aucun des deux tours 2 8
turbo 4 tours de 6 1
moi je le fais retour à je suis 3 4 ième
a pas d'eau pour ça que j'aurais
commencé par tour à suite en plus il
fait tourner la pendule à fond regarde
dupouy est restée la semaine fut dix
minutes très bien vu de la part de mag
où il a peut-être pas les gagner mais
bon il fait tourner la pendule à fond
qui entoure ces quatre apprend à will
get far tour f1 mais la tour et grand
côté 7 nuls sa recette tour à quatre
noms se tait sur la mort et dans l'euro
cotait comme noah les lotos joue très
moderne l'auteur joue très très mal
parce qu'il connaît pas les théories des
trucs ici soit je suis l'auteur connaît
pas les théories parce que quand le roi
est sûre h à cause des dommages foutyou
moi ici bien sûr c'est une tuerie mais
il n'est pas allé les basiques mais
c'est sûr qu'ils peuvent
sauf que cette finale théorique est très
souvent notre gagnée par
sorry qu'il ya un pion tout simplement
parce que ça pousse ça pousse à bouger à
abandonner les noirs pierre kamat non du
coup c'est quoi le score toujours plus +
5 à 8 minutes au caire une façon il est
très heureux mais ce qu'il cède 3 que
vous l'êtes de cette photo 3 fawcett
tirofijo danse attia faut des six qu'est
ce que tu penses avec fabien on pense
que quand le match est fini ça devrait
être bon est ce que je pense mais à quoi
ça sert le tutorat le droit d'abandonner
en fait moquer mais par exemple le cas
de richard jouer ce match contre les
chinois auraient d'abord contredire puis
après contribué lundi par exemple on a
un dacquois à la fois première nul avec
le noir la gagne est deuxième avec les
bras à la gagne et 3e et aidera on n'a
pas eu 4e partiel et cannois avec les
bras ça y est le match de gagné
oui je pense que moi à quoi ça sert de
jouer ce qui l'intéresse pression de jeu
et en plus il faut quand même être il
faut quand même avoir de l'épi tir pour
se récupérer parce que c'est de la
torture des gens non c'est dur ok vas il
a l'air de bien le prendre quand même il
est tout sourire
il accable le souhait encore san ça va
ça fait un bon moment où quand c'est
tout ce que vous
son sourire un regard mabhouh est très
heureux que ça y est encore heureux
qu'ils pensaient que ray dame prend 1,4
f5 je pense on avait un petit décalage
[Musique]
tient maintenant je sens que quelques
rayons ferme et l'autre chrétien trois
équipes revient voilà que ce triste vie
nice mais ces gens ni sûre et calme tout
le temps mais dans l'avion il souriait
comme ça tout le temps aussi
non point seule fois c'est la première
fois que je le vois comme ça et il
sourit vraiment beaucoup
c'est un gros gros score ouais c'est
pour ça grands enfants n'ont pas ce
plaisir
je pense que et les intérêts pour
compagne et de pose et il joue pour le
public l'air mais je pense aussi
l'habillement
mais je passe sur les gagner cela si
f3ar 3f de sailly il est impossible de
poser un regard très froid
intermédiaires et tf2 intermédiaire mans
par exemple par exemple penser le plus
clean on se doit des katas c'est très
clean aussi parce que tu peux pas
stopper les d'opium hockey hebdo bien
sûr normalement c'est le premier le
premier réflexe ya là je pense tu tentes
des processus pour se passe jamais un
prêt boubrik bizarre et ouais ok t'es à
ce four pour voir faut je crois donc que
tu abandonnes mais aussi était-il
assistons et la pendule pourra plus
jouer au 6 6 6 2
mais je trouve que ça me fait quand même
assez le scénario du match finalement je
pense que ce bilan ne méritait donc je
pense que ça reflète plus ou moins leurs
rapports de force et le jour avec moi
plus fort au littoral et avant le match
était pas si sûr en mai parmi les fautes
qui sera connu dans cette
moi je serai ces deux réputés les lignes
où ils n'arrivent pas d'autres étaient
calmes relâche des offres avec le cac
volley sur f5
non le stonewall avec fleuve qu'à terme
en donc voilà donc là maintenant il joue
sept fils d'or à l' école moldave donc
elle a à la bo la gamme par exemple ben
c'est ce que la fois lieu dès le début
mais d'essayer de nous a un peu changé
le cours de choses et m'a tuer parce que
sinon les gens non alors il y en a pas
mal qui ont qui sont confiantes pour mdm
je suis vraiment inquiet alors contre
qui jouait ce qu'on a est ce que
quelqu'un sait ce que ça peut être
intéressante ce qui tend la de d'avoir
le tirage au sort il est très probable
que iana déjà les appareils et moi donc
dites nous si vous êtes au courant j'ai
pas comment trouver
nous aussi on espère pour un jouet mais
vous voyez donc ça dépend conteur qui
joue aussi le niveau de confiance parce
que si ce n'est pas messi sait qu'une
chose
surtout poursuit une autre chose si
c'est votre chèque c'est une troisième
chose ça peut pas être grisha c'est que
pour intégrer charge s'opposant va être
n'est pas non plus il ya quatre têtes de
série chemin mais le problème c'est que
ces world chef qui organise donc c'est
dur d'avoir des enfants
ils ont du mal pour mettre à jour les
informations rapidement mais c'est sûr
ces sorties parce qu il est 23h arias et
un trieur de fois je pense que parfois
moi toujours qu'au pérou du gone by and
blood des créateurs de 50 blessés je
pense rien de bien sûr ceux qui misent
sur billère
non il n'ya aucune information sur leur
twitter
malheureusement même source qui n'a pas
écrit apparemment saoul top ce qui écrit
tout le temps des trucs inutiles qu il a
fini par y gagne ça fait de nouveau +5
aulas qui appuient comme ça où en
chaussettes sur facebook
normalement la bonne technique de
rencontrer lé système avec cavaliers h3k
relève 4 vite c'est de jeu que vous
laissez 6 avec le dépôt 5
parce qu'un ornement de telle finale
comme celles là sont toujours beaux bien
pour les bois à thaon j'étais donc je
pense pas que c'est les murs des
réactions sauf que ok je comprends qu on
s'en fou de jalousie ou de mettre à
temps
ok je revins dire l'article en fait mais
non il m'aide pas
ok peut-être fort autres chefs
[Musique]
non mais c'est quand même incroyable de
pas de pas trouvé moi à chaque fois que
je vois sur le site de world cheese
j'arrive pas à trouver quoi que ce soit
en fait c'est mon problème éternel et
chez ce cas il est sur tesco sur
wordpress pardon mais il ne voit
toujours pas bon qu'est ce qui se passe
sinon sur l'échiquier hockey après pas
mal de coups après si les noirs sont
conquois un petit peu millions - sauf
que normalement bien sûr doit se
terminer avec nous pas dans cette
cadence la danse en cadence l'air bien
sûr je pense que le noir vont gagner à
près de 4 après de beckett et la
tactique sur le vo argent ils ont trouvé
mais ils peuvent pas nous dire dans les
dents les commentaires faits loana mais
c'est quand même incroyable la bombe
sont ensuite tous peur même quand c'est
pas facile avec le mobile quand ils
peuvent ils pourraient dire quoi non
mais avoue quand même que si l'on le
truc c'est quand même navarra enfin bon
choix assez bon toi un très beau choix
s'arrête à massac je pense qu'on a
toutes les raisons d'être au piège dans
lequel il a saigné de la parano je pense
que le couple de poigne jeu parce que
déjà six en avertir la tête avec le noir
sauve internautes loi a parce qu'avec
ceux qui ricanent la guerre au camp nou
il connaît pas son soutien à aa
donc je pense que toutes les raisons
d'être optimiste et s'ils gagnent
d'abord à ça va ça risque d'être dans
les prochaines c'est pas mes amis je
suis pas tricherie turgot fra c'est
parfait juste c'est peut-être le moins
bon 2007
navarra percée historique mois les homos
alfort 2007 32 tout le temps tiens elle
va sauver son honneur quand même
dernière cette dernière pour cette
dernière partie
il va sauver 50 le meur de la russie
s'il a sauvé grand chose et grichka et
igor fait ce que ça veut dire que dès
les premières charges eau avec le bon
message à ce qu'un bon apparemment vie
tu dois l'avouer je pense d'art peur de
doublons je respecte vie tout comme moi
je ne pense pas que c'est le joueur le
moins agréable pour que je pense que
double aurait pu être l'avait devancé
justin mauvaise nouvelle non général
bondoux beaufou il peut être désagréable
pour n'importe qui en fait attend tu
veux pas tenter un nom il ya vas-y fais
dans votre horaire bateaux sur la zone à
qui le tour je droit de nouvelles de
grave ni que pas je pense que tout ce
nouvel que se promène avec ses gosses
près du lac de miélan de genève
comment s'appelle la crème oui donc je
pense que c'est tout ce nouvel ces
derniers temps leur ils voient les
oligarques russes et se promènent autour
de la chanson on est aussi méchantes
langues plus dangereux non que la barre
à chaque round j'ai pas dit qui chante
musique et chaque fois c'est une très
bonne nouvelle le signe mais
malheureusement avant on ne voit pas le
voir c'est qu'il a écrit a pas longtemps
sur twitter aurait fait encore de
devenir champion du monde
mais peut-être qu'en tellers lra 50 ans
des îles vous pourra devenir de chez les
seniors g et mitterrand tu penses sur
les vétérans m'hamed double assez
mauvais pour mariette que va se faire
défoncer je pense doit favori n'est pas
cohérent pas que c'est rien n'est
prévisible de se voir juste rien car
pour 8,6 à ce poste non je ne pense pas
car parfois et la part des affaires
en russie que je pense pas qu'il va
jamais bougé de la russie parce que les
troupes business vous savez les les
députés dans le parlement donc ne va pas
vivre à texas non non non tout cas c'est
une bonne nouvelle
driller faux avis qu aux as peut-être
que vous aviez compris du nom brière a
vécu au texas je sais pas essayer le
bouge et où il a vécu ou pendant
plusieurs années
donc on va se qualifier vlad pour
revenir sur la nouvelle tu donnes
combien de pourcentage de chance au
hockey une chose c'est clair que l'issue
du match et on voyait la voir beaucoup
plus clair que l'issue du match s'achève
et hugo beaucoup beaucoup parce que
sacha vie du bourg je donne soit 140 et
ouvrir la voie rage dont 4 avant la donc
on est quand même bien parce que peu
importe les cadences je donne toujours
un gros pourcentage mais c'est
intéressant qu'ils qui risquent de son
adversaire dans les prochains jours
ce serait le penalty quand vous voyez
les 1 seule victoire sous ouais parce
que qui est sensuelle et vous il suffit
de lire mon mieux mais il est partout en
plus haut qu'on suit l'air moins pataude
mieux que celle de l'air donc en fait il
ya plusieurs joueurs à chez nous et qui
se ressemblent énormément content et
ouvriers n'est pas celui de l'air
d'accord et à présent il est évident que
renner que sur les rideaux droit le mois
ford de demain ans et sera donc et vous
est ce dire celles que ça sent que ça je
crois que sur ce qui s'est dit et redit
da en plus les deux sont très bien parce
que tout ça il encaisse à mon avis assez
facilement aussi
non d'autant c'est beaucoup moins claire
ok mais valve encaissés dans l'ouverture
toute assez sans problème dans les
ouvertures mais d'audace toujours
''j'ai imminent le caire ils valent
encaissés dans l'ouverture voici votre
possible que l'on redevienne beaucoup
plus haut triki le problème c'est que ce
dernier patrick y célébrer ce jour
espagne les patries qui il joue car
aucun des patries qui joue c'est sûr il
est en cours - triki adoubait les prix
qui parce qu'il peut jouer les
françaises match aller de ces îles et le
problème d'eau du gua est difficilement
prévisible
tandis que nouveau lieu le rieuse saint
pierre bourgeois est encore plus
prévisible que mes propos
non mais en fait oui tu as raison duda
si jamais ils s'échappent de l'ouverture
c'est pas sûr de l'anc et c'est vide
l'air c'est sûr de l'encaissé soit dans
l'ouverture soit dans le milieu de jeu
soit dans les rapides
en fait tu peux l'encaissé partout des
gens ont surtout donné ses draps et
surtout en effet d'additionnels est à la
portée de la portée de la loi
ouais trop sucrés non alors que 12 à
trépas sûr c'est vrai beaucoup d'eux
afin qu'ils doutent a maintenant 12 en
quelque sorte celui de l'air en 97
mais malheureusement les 1 cuil donc c
est l'air de rien 23 alors attends on a
comme une enfant un bain portante de à
peron qui dit qu'on a des appariements
mais ils ont pas l'air dans le bon ordre
donc on sait pas en fait encore une fois
le top heidi ce que wes et ses camardes
chess d'auteur est vraiment fort
boycotter tous des cheveux parmi les
joueurs les plus doués se joue comme il
n'a pas encore réussi de construire une
usine de préparation d'une fusion qu'est
ce que ça veut dire une usine usines ça
veut dire que le joueur est en train de
manger sont bizarres mois de travail est
en train de s'effectuer des copains
plutôt dans l'autre bout du monde à ça
tu peux te dresser un top [ __ ] texas
plus de traces en lui mais le travail
est en train de se faire ce sale usines
du travail et quand il s'agit de je sais
pas faire en stage trouver un mec et
travailler leur nom dans ce point nous
ou non
c'est artisanal j'attends que jordan qui
dit pour le peuple poursuit douleur à
part la défense il ya que l'attak qui
pêche - ou non mais c'est une blague de
camelot mais tu connais peut-être pas le
roi arthur un repère et à part de la
défense et que l'attak kifech pas s'ils
savent pas défendre leur forteresse et
il n'a pas attaqué les autres mais à
part ça ça va mais donc bon bah écoutes
je pense qu'on va laisser tout le monde
allait suivre les interviews
sur le live officielle tap le met un
petit raid et nous on se retrouve demain
à 14h pour suivre maxime ouimet monkey
panneaux commentaires un peu plus
philosophique de demain hier à bois
comme pour le barreau beaucoup plus de
temps de se gratter de langue autour des
questions plus profondes
non mais honnêtement ce sera plus
intéressant que ce qu'on a vécu ce soir
il ya beaucoup plus dangereux c'est
maxime c'est les candidats pas demain
c'est le vrai début de la saison en
réalité au web ont joué au foot pour le
titre ouais pour la couronne demain
c'est le vrai faille point pour elle
donc on espère que vous serez nombreux
je mettrais bien évidemment des liens
sur les réseaux sociaux on vous
demandera de partager très massivement
bien évidemment sur twitter sur facebook
comme toujours on vous dit à demain donc
je suis avec vous ici point dans deux
semaines châu